- It's important as like
a Japanese voice actor
to be able to voice animals!
- Do animals?
- Do you have to audition
for animal roles?
- I already had it in
my voice reel, and so.
(everyone laughing)
- Can you do some
animals voices right now?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Shu imitates dog barking)
I can do a cat as well.
(Shu imitates cat meowing)
(soft music)
- Hello and welcome to another
episode of "Trash Taste."
I am the host for today, Garnt.
And with me are, as usual, the boys.
And, as you can see, I am
not alone on this side.
I am reclaiming the host chair,
(Shu laughing)
as we have a guest on.
Would you like to introduce
yourself to the crowd?
- Yes, hi everyone.
My name is Shu Uchida and
I'm a voice actor in Japan.
Yeah, nice to meet you guys.
(everyone laughing)
- Just keeping it brief.
- You're not just any voice actor, though.
- Yeah.
- You're our best mate.
- Anime voice actor.
- Yeah, anime voice actor.
- Because we're an anime
podcast, as the viewership knows.
- Yeah, of course.
- Yeah.
- You know the 5% of the
time we talk about anime?
(everyone laughing)
- This is one of those 5%.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Actually, yeah, I think this
might be, like the official,
well, first of all, you're
the official first guest
on the new set.
- Yay.
- We're not even counting Chris.
We're not counting Chris.
- Thank you!
- Chris ain't a guest anymore.
- [Joey] Chris ain't a guest anymore.
- This is the first real guest
episode of the new studio.
- Exactly, first real
guest, but also like,
I think people have
pointed out, in your accent
or figured out from your
accent that you're Australian.
- Yes, I am Australian.
- Yeah, and I'm like-
- And you're Australian too, right?
- And I literally went to school with you.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's so weird, it's like, yeah.
- Yeah, so to explain, off
screen, we just found out
that these two went to the
same kinda school together,
and they know each other
as like childhood friends
or something like that.
So do you guys wanna explain that?
What happened with that?
- Well, like the Japanese
community in Australia,
like the parents, they'll
send like their kids
to like this thing called Saturday school.
So we have school on Saturdays,
from around 10 to like one p.m.
And then yeah, we were
in different classes
'cause you were in a
higher grade than I was.
- Yeah, I think I'm two
years older than you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, so,
but I was in the same
class as her older sister.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- For about seven years or something.
- [Shu] Yeah, yeah.
- And because, and
again, because the school
is so small, because the
community is so small,
you naturally hang out with kids
who are younger than you
and older than you.
- Yeah.
- So yeah, like I would see Shu
in like the playground and stuff.
- It's like the meme where like,
every Asian knows each other,
but it's actually true.
(everyone laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- In Australia.
- In Australia, every Japanese
person knows each other.
Yeah, so like yeah, so
not only did I go to,
I was in the same class
as her sister but like,
yeah, we used to like hang out like every,
not too often though, right?
- Yeah not too often, but like-
- But like we had so many mutual friends
that I think it's just like
naturally, we knew each other.
- Okay.
- Yeah so, and now she's
an anime voice actor.
- And now you both work
in the anime industry.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's so weird.
- It's so bizarre.
- Like yeah.
- I gotta ask like, in this
like Japanese community,
were there many people who wanted to work
in the anime industry?
'Cause you know how it is
with like the weeb culture,
it's like, you see an
anime fan and they're like,
"Oh, I wanna work in anime."
And like, All right weeb, all right.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But like, what was it like for
like the Japanese community?
- I don't know.
I mean, I think at that point,
I wasn't even really thinking
about that at all.
- Oh, really?
- I think--
- Too busy enjoying the weeb life.
- I was too busy enjoying the weeb life.
- Getting involved.
- Yeah exactly.
So I was like, I don't know,
'cause I think even back then,
like I knew I always wanted
to live and work in Japan,
but I think the whole anime industry side
of things was just kinda like a dream.
- It's just so mystical, no
one knows anything about it.
- Well that's the thing, right?
It's like, I wouldn't,
like back then, I was like,
How do you even like begin to try
and get into an industry like that?
So it's like, if I end up working in it,
it's like, cool.
But like, it wasn't like I
was chasing the weeb dream.
Just like, I'm definitely gonna like work
for Kyoto Animation when I'm older,
work for Studio Trigger when I'm older.
- You're like, I was on
that hustle since age 10.
(everyone laughing)
I was on that hustle to get
into the anime industry.
- I was on that Sakuga grind.
(everyone laughing)
- Well, it's like, no,
but I mean, I dunno.
Did you know anybody?
Like, what was it like for you?
Like, did you always wanted to
become an anime voice actress
or whatever?
- Well for me, I was like,
I was like opposite to you and I was like,
I really wanna become a voice actor
and I'm gonna become a voice actor.
- Oh you're on that grind.
- Okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- And so, but I didn't
know anyone around me
who wanted to become someone
who was in the anime industry.
So like, for me, it was just me
wanting to come to Japan
to get into this industry.
- Because I think the
majority of the people
at our Saturday school
weren't even really thinking
to be in Japan.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right.
- I think, 'cause like, even to this day,
like most of my Japanese friends
from that Saturday school,
most of them still live in Sydney.
- [Shu] Same, same.
- And are just like
normal, English-speaking,
everyday job kinda thing
so it's like, yeah.
I think Shu and I are the weird ones.
(Shu laughing)
- We are!
- I mean, I already hear
the word, Saturday school
and I'm like, you guys are crazy.
My God, five days of
school was enough for me,
one more day in the weekend?
Nah, get, mother, mother,
I am not attending
another school day, okay?
- I fought like hell to
get out of Sunday school.
It was my biggest battle of life.
- I mean, to be fair, like I personally
didn't even see it as like a school.
For me, it was more just like a hangout,
to hang out with all my Japanese friends.
- They tricked you, Joey.
- Same.
- They fuckin' tricked you.
- Same, yeah.
- They sold you on another day of school.
(Shu and Garnt laughing)
- I mean like again, it's not like
I didn't learn anything, right?
Like obviously, especially when you go to,
'cause the school we had, it
started from kindergarten,
so like what?
You're like four or five years old.
- [Shu] Yeah, no, I think so.
- All the way up until ninth
grade, where you're about--
- So you were brainwashed into liking it.
- Indoctrinated.
I'm just hearing indoctrination here.
Get 'em while they're
young, build a habit,
and they'll just, they'll love it.
They'll learn to love it.
- They'll love it,
they'll love it.
- It's like what?
Stockholm syndrome.
(all laughing)
- I think that obviously, the
viewers are probably wondering
what are some shows that you've voiced in?
Because that's probably
gonna be the first thing
they wanna know.
- Oh yeah.
- Probably we should mention
that and then we could chat.
- And then we can go deep dive, yeah.
- Yeah, I voiced Mia Taylor
from "Love Live! School
Idol Festival ALL STARS."
I also voiced Warspite,
Ark Royal, Perth, Mikura,
and Gambier Bay from "KanKore,"
"Kantai Collection KanKore."
- That's a big collection right there.
(Shu and Garnt laughs)
- I also voiced Fujiwara-san
from "Asobi Asobase," yeah.
- Right.
- And yeah and a lot more.
I'm like, I'm in like "Doraemon."
- You're in "Doraemon?"
- Yeah, sometimes.
- I think that's the
true weeb dream, right?
Where it's like you're in a show
that has literally shaped your childhood.
- Yeah, yeah.
I'm also in like "Shin-chan."
- Oh, really?
- You're in "Shin-chan?"
- Like just a bit, yeah, yeah, sometimes.
- That's so cool!
- I'm gonna scream.
(everyone laughing)
- Like I mostly do like dogs and cats.
- Hey, you're in, you're in, you're in.
Run with it, run with it.
- But yeah, yeah.
I'm in like anime's and games
and stuff like that so, yeah.
- Awesome.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah.
- I feel like you're downplaying it.
You should be like, I
am in anime and games.
- Yeah.
- Not like--
- That's not a thing most people can say.
- I don't think you realize
the literal hundreds
and thousands of people
who watch our show,
who only dream to be in your position.
- Oh, really?
- Exactly.
You're actual real anime voice actress,
that's like most people dream to be that,
and you fucking managed to
achieve it, so congratulations.
- I'm an anime, no, I'm a voice actor!
(everyone laughing)
- I am an anime.
- I am anime.
- I just wanna point out,
'cause I know the viewers
are gonna point it out as well,
how comically large I
look sitting next to you.
'Cause I'm seeing myself
on screen and I'm like,
if you thought you just
tuned into the newest season
of "Attack on Titan" tonight,
I assure you this is "Trash Taste."
- It's literally the meme
of like, 6'0" versus 5'11".
- Especially on that camera,
I look so comically large,
with that perspective.
- It's a wide angle,
the people on the edges
are gonna look bigger.
- To be fair, I look, in this camera,
I look massive next to Connor, so.
- You are massive next to me, Joey.
- I am massive.
- Joey's massive.
- I'm just built like that.
- Trapped into your Saturday school.
- Yeah.
(Garnt laughing)
- He's built different.
- Yeah.
Just come out of Saturday
school like a Chad.
- So you, mentioned that you
wanted to be a voice actor
from a young age?
- Yes, yes.
- When did that start then?
Walk me through the
process, I'm interested.
- Well, like I started
to, I started liking anime
because my sister used to like anime,
and then so I used to watch anime with her
and I wanted to become a voice actor
when I was in primary school.
- Oh, very young then.
- That's very young.
- I didn't even know that was like a job
when I was a primary school.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- I think it was like funny acting people.
- [Shu] Yeah.
- I just thought the
characters just existed.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(everyone laughing)
- I was like there aren't people,
there aren't real people involved.
- Goku's there somewhere
in the world, right?
Yeah, yeah, I'm sure he exists.
- Yeah, like I was watching
"Bleach" with my sister,
and you know Hitsugaya?
- Yeah.
- He's voiced by Paku Romi-san.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- She's like a woman,
and she's like voice acting a boy.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so I was really
like fascinated by that.
And I was like, "Oh, I really
wanna be a voice actor."
And then from then on, I was kinda like,
I told my parents
that I wanted to become
a voice actor in Japan.
And you know like, typical
Asian parents, they're like,
"Um, uh, like maybe that
isn't like really your"-
- "You want to be an artist?"
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "What is a voice actor?
I've never heard of that job before.
Do you need a degree to get it?"
- Yeah, yeah.
And what was interesting
was that at Saturday school,
I used to get super low
marks, like in my test.
So my parents were like,
Well, you're getting such
low marks in Japanese,
like how are you gonna
become a voice actor in Japan
where it's like, you
need to be really good
at speaking Japanese and reading Japanese?
- Right, right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, and then so yeah, my
parents were like against me,
but I was like, "I wanna
become a voice actor in Japan."
So yeah, in high school I
kind of started auditioning
for like the schools, the
voice acting schools in Japan.
- Oh wow.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, what age in high school?
- I think like 16, 17?
- Wow.
- So like, I would work part-time
and then I'll save money
and then I'll book a flight to Japan.
- Oh my God.
- To audition, yeah.
- Damn. 16?
- Damn, you are determined.
- I was like, I was like working like,
like four, five times a week.
And then on like, during school holidays,
I'll be working like six
times a week or like,
just when the-
- Holy fuck.
- You were really on that grind.
- Yeah!
- Yeah, shit.
I was like, super like,
"I wanna become..."
Yeah, and then like, and a lot
of the places told me that,
'cause I live overseas,
it's kind of like--
- Hard.
- Yeah, it's kind of hard, yeah.
But then, I finally
like passed the audition
and they're like, "Please
come to the school."
And then so, I had to go to Japan.
But at that time I was still in uni.
- Okay.
- And like my parents were like,
"Well isn't it better if
you kinda like finish uni
and then go to school?"
- Normal parent stuff.
- Yeah, yeah.
And so, I was kinda like,
"Yeah, maybe, but no."
(everyone laughing)
- And so, during the
holidays, I like worked more,
and then I saved up a lot of money.
And you know in Australia,
it's like when you're 18,
you can kind of decide
everything yourself.
So like, I kind of quit uni
without telling my parents.
- Oh.
- I think that's like the
worst thing you can do, right?
It's like number one no-no.
- That's like, one step away from eloping.
(Shu laughing)
- Holy fuck, I've never actually
heard an Asian kid do that.
I'm just like, I'm just,
I felt that in my soul, man.
Like a thousand of my ancestors
just screamed right there.
- You are the 1% of Asians.
(everyone laughing)
- Is this what happens
when an Asian unlocks,
like their final form?
- The woke Asian!
(everyone laughing)
Third eye open.
- I feel like I can quit.
I feel like I just witnessed
ultra instinct IRL, man.
Jesus Christ.
(Shu laughing)
- And so, it doesn't stop there.
Like I quit uni and then
I didn't tell my parents,
and then--
- But you knew
you were gonna quit uni for awhile,
or was it just kinda like,
Fuck it, I'm doing it?"
- Well, before going to uni, I was gonna,
I wasn't really actually gonna go to uni,
but then my parents were like,
"Can you go to uni for at least one year?"
- Please, please go to uni.
- And then so I was like, okay.
And then I went to uni
for one year and then,
yeah and, wait so what was
the question you asked?
(everyone laughing)
- Like when you went
into uni you were like,
"Yeah, I'm not gonna stick with this?"
Or was it like, you just had
enough and you were like,
"Fuck it, I'm gonna move to Japan?"
- Yeah, I went to the classes
there and I was like, nah.
Like this is stupid.
(everyone laughing)
- Hell nah, hell nah.
- Yeah, nah.
- I had that idea, but I was like,
"But I guess I did sign up."
Like, I'm not Zuckerberg,
I don't have an idea,
I can't just quit.
And do what?
- Yeah.
And then, so I booked the flights to Japan
without telling my parents.
- Fuck that, Jesus.
- And I think around a
week before the flights,
I told my parents that.
(everyone laughing)
- See ya!
- Because my parents were so
against me going to Japan.
- [Connor] Oh, yeah, of course, of course.
- So, like a week before,
I told my parents,
and by then I had already
like, booked the packaging.
What is it like the, the people who come
to take your package to send it to Japan.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like the post people?
And so yeah, I told them-
- Oh, so they just like showed
up and they're all like,
"What's all this?
What's all this then?"
- Yeah, yeah.
- So you literally just, sorted
out all of the logistics?
- Yeah.
- And then-
- Oh my God.
- One day before like the
package goes, you're like,
"Mom, I'm leaving."
- BT dubs.
(everyone laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "By the way, Mom, going to Japan."
- I have to ask, when you told them,
did like boss music start playing or what?
Like what happened when you told them?
- Well, I think my parents
weren't expecting me
to like act in that way, 'cause in school,
I was that girl that was like,
I would like study a lot and then--
- Yeah.
- Obedient.
- Yeah, yeah, and then--
- Yeah, yeah.
- Then actually you'd be like, psych.
(everyone laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
And then, so when I told
her, she was kinda like,
"Okay."
(everyone laughing)
- Just like top 10 anime
betrayals in real life, right?
- Yeah, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] Jesus.
- Yeah, but then like, 'cause
18 in Australia is like,
you're considered like an
adult, but 18 in Japan,
you're still considered like-
- A child.
- A child, right?
- 20 right?
- Yeah 20.
- 20 is an adult, yeah.
- And then, so I had
booked the flights to Japan
but I hadn't like, rented
any like house or anything.
And I was like, "Oh, I
could just stay in a hotel
until I can rent a house."
But then after going to Japan,
I realized that you couldn't book a house,
like you couldn't rent a
house when you're like 18 so-
- Yeah.
- You can't?
- Yeah, you can't.
- You need parents' permission.
- Yeah.
- Oh no.
(Garnt laughing)
Oh no!
- And because my parents were
really against me, right?
They wouldn't, they'll be like, "Nah."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And so, I went through all my contacts
and I contacted all my
friends and I was like,
"Is anyone in Japan?
Like, living in Japan,
can I like live with you?"
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And then there was like one girl
that went to the same school,
Saturday school, and she-
- The Saturday school, paying
off the dividends, man.
(everyone laughing)
- That's what the torture was all for!
It's all worth it in the end.
- I'm jealous.
- And then she like, luckily,
she actually had a bunk bed in her room.
- Mm hm.
- And the reason why she had
a bunk bed in her room-
- What just randomly?
- No, well, because, like her
parents would be coming over
from Australia to Japan,
like once in awhile.
- Right, right, right.
- So, she was like, Oh, I could just,
have like a bunk bed so
that they could sleep there
when they come.
And so yeah, she was like,
"Well, I have a bunk bed
and if you're fine with that,
then we can live together."
So we lived together for awhile
and then I started going
to the school there.
- Right.
- And that's how it all kind of started.
- [Joey] Wow.
- That's a fuckin' bad-ass story, man.
Holy shit.
- Plot on movie.
(everyone laughing)
Jesus Christ.
- That's literally like the equivalent
of like the OG American
dream kind of story,
where you just like, you pack your bags,
you go to like LA or whatever,
and you just figure it out,
and that's kind of what you did.
- Yeah.
- It was literally like, I'm
on a quest to find myself.
(everyone laughing)
It's like that level, right?
It's like, parents won't
hold me back, I got this.
That's so cool.
- I assume, obviously having
native Japanese is a big plus.
I've heard that in Japan,
they're really strict
with like pronunciation
and then voice acting
has to be like perfect.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
I still have problems with my accent.
Like sometimes.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, 'cause like, you
know, even if a kanji,
there's like so many ways of
reading, like the same kanji,
and then like for accents, it's like,
it also depends on the sentence,
like accent changes, you know.
And so like, yeah, I still have,
I'm still kind of learning my accent.
But yeah, yeah, I'm getting used to it.
- I mean, yeah, I feel
that like, especially,
I feel like just voice acting
agencies, like anywhere,
in any country is like
quite high standards,
but I feel Japan especially
has some pretty insane standards.
- Oh, because it's one of
the most sought after jobs
in Japan, right?
- Right, yeah, yeah.
- There's some huge competition for it.
- Mm-hm, there is, yeah.
- After YouTuber.
(everyone laughing)
- Of course, it is.
- All the kids in Japan are
like, number one, YouTuber,
number two, voice actor.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Well, you know, you've seen
loads of videos about it,
of like people going into these schools,
and it's like a military camp.
- [Shu] Yeah, they're really strict.
- And you feel so bad, because
you're like all these people,
most of the people are gonna
have their dreams crushed
because they're not gonna make it.
- Yeah, what is like the kind
(mug clinking)
of daily routine for, Jesus Christ.
(everyone laughing)
What is like the daily routine
for like schools like that?
'Cause like you only hear
about voice acting schools
in Japan but like, obviously,
I don't think any of us have been to it
or know anything about it.
- I mean-
- I'm so sorry.
- Oh, its all right.
It depends on the school,
like some schools,
you have to go there
like five times a week,
some school, they only
have it like once a week.
And I went to one that
was only like once a week,
and the teachers there
would be really strict.
And in Japanese you call
it like, Taiikukai-kei.
It's really like, they're
really strict and like-
- Right.
- Yeah, so like, we do like,
accent and pronunciation,
and we also do like,
what is it in English, like Katsuzetsu.
- Oh like,
- Like, so that like,
you know, to fix like lisps or--
- Yeah!
- Oh, okay.
- To like, be able to
pronounce like all syllables,
correctly, I think.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I don't know what
it's called in English.
- [Shu] Yeah, I don't
know what it's called.
- Pronunciation?
- Yeah, pronunciation I guess.
- Enunciation.
- Oh, enunciation, enunciation.
- Very, very important part.
- Yeah.
- People overlook.
- Yeah, yeah.
But then, because the teachers
were like really strict,
by like six months into starting school,
like half of the students wouldn't,
would start not coming to school.
- Right.
- And they'll just kinda like disappear.
- Yeah.
- Disappear, right.
- Kinda like uni then.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So is it like kind of a strict process
of even getting into this school?
Like you mentioned, you
had to audition a bunch
and you have to-
- Yeah.
This also depends on the school,
like some schools are really strict.
Some schools, they're not as strict.
- Mm-hm.
- Right.
- Because like, you learn
everything at school.
So like, I think they're
looking for people
with like nice voices or like, you know.
- Right, right.
- Okay.
- People who have like, potential.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Did they ever like kick
anyone out, they're like,
"Yo, you're terrible, go home?"
- Like, well the auditions, like-
- Kinda like that, I guess.
- Yeah.
Well it's kinda like,
it comes through post,
like whether you passed or not.
- Ah, oh, oh.
- So it's like, yeah.
- Oh, they don't wanna tell you in person.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it's kinda like, you go to the audition
and they're like, "Okay, thank you."
And you go home, and
then like a week later-
- That's just such typical like,
passive-aggressive Japanese trait, right?
- You're terrible, goodbye.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So how long would you typically study
at the voice acting school?
- I went to the voice
acting school for two years,
some people only go for
like a year as well, so.
- And you don't get any jobs in that time?
It's like purely just studying?
- Well, for me it was, I got
a job when I was at school
and that was only because I
was able to speak English.
- It's not common that you would get-
- It's not really common, yeah.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- I guess you have the advantage
of being bilingual, right?
- Yeah.
- So you get like that,
you get those English jobs, as well.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I was just talking to Connor
how like being bilingual in this country,
or in any Asian country,
if you want a job in that
country, it's just like so easy.
- Yeah, it is.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like a cheat code almost.
- I mean that's, you know,
one of the big reasons
why I wanted to move here, right?
It's because like, in Australia,
no one really gives a shit
if you can speak Japanese.
- Yeah, that's true, that's so true.
- It's like the only job
you'd probably be able to get
is like teaching Japanese on
like, the Saturday school,
for instance, right?
But it's like, even then, it's like a lot
of Japanese teachers in Australia
don't even really speak
that good of a Japanese.
- Yeah.
- In the alternative timeline,
you are an interpreter
for the president of Australia.
- Yeah, right.
That's probably the only like job, yeah.
- Your just talking to like the president
or the prime minister of Japan
and Joey's behind him like,
telling him in the ear.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's probably like the
only like, real high-end job
you could probably get
if you know Japanese.
But like here for example,
like every company,
in every field is looking for
someone who speaks English.
So it's just natural
progression to just come here.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Exactly.
- What I wanna know is
like, the things you learn
in voice acting school, do
they specifically teach you
how to sound like an anime character?
'Cause like, I've noticed obviously,
as it's common sense
that anime characters sound very different
from how people usually speak.
- Right, yeah.
- So, what goes into like
learning how to speak like that?
- This also depends on like,
which kind of teacher you have,
but some teachers are
based on like, acting.
So they're more like, instead of like,
sounding like an anime character,
like they want you to focus
on your acting skills.
But some teachers actually do tell you,
like you need to be
more like, over the top.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Say this line, 'cause
like anime characters,
they're like over the top.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So like, yeah, yeah, so yeah.
- Okay, so you've been
in school for two years,
how does it then
transition into being like,
you're a professional now, start working?
Like is that like a set
end date at the school?
Or is it like, they just, they're like,
"You're ready now kid,
go on, start acting."
(everyone laughing)
- "Start acting, kid."
- Act, act, act.
- For my school, there was like a set date
that you finish school.
And before you finish school,
you have like auditions
to get into an agency.
- That's very Japanese, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because I feel like in
the West, they're just like,
"All right, you're done.
Fuck off, good luck."
- Yeah.
- "Make it work kid."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But yeah, they'll be
like, staff there like,
looking at you and usually
you'll be handed like a script,
like 15 minutes before you
actually act in front of the-
- Oh, Jesus.
- Right.
- Yeah, the people.
- Oh damn, okay.
- And so, yeah-
- What is the point of that?
'Cause it's like, that doesn't happen
on a regular job, right?
- No, no.
- You don't show up to
the studio not knowing
what anime you're gonna
be in and being like,
"Here's the script,
you're recording in 10 minutes."
- It's really common, at least in English,
that you wouldn't know,
you wouldn't see the script
until you're actually
recording it, though.
- Yeah, but in Japan, it's
like way, way before, right?
- I mean like, for like
narration or like sometimes,
there's like times when they
give it to you on that day,
but like in regards to
like anime and games,
it's more like, you get
several days in advance.
- Yeah, because of the pre-planning stage
for anime and games here is insanely long.
- [Shu] Yeah.
- I think 'cause that
sometimes in English,
they're still changing the
lines while you're getting-
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Shu] Oh.
- 'Cause they might change them.
Or like maybe, you know, they'll change it
while you're doing the lines,
I've had that happen before.
He goes like, "I don't like this anymore,
I wanna change it."
I'm like, "Okay."
- Yeah, because when I did the stuff
for "Pop Team Epic," they
gave me the script like,
four weeks before I actually went in.
- [Shu] Yeah.
- No NDA either, right?
- Huh?
- No NDA either?
- No NDA.
They gave me, I talked
about this on the podcast,
but they literally gave
me a CD of the episode.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, we get that.
- Did they do that for you?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Is that just like a common thing?
- Yeah, it's like anime recordings, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
You got like a CD beforehand
and you check that at home
and then you see how long
you're like, line is.
- And then you kinda
like check out the timing
of like when to start?
- Yeah.
- Did you have to like
sign anything saying
I won't show this to anyone?
- No.
- What?
- That's insane!
- Yeah.
- Dude, the trust system here is nuts.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's crazy.
This video is sponsored by Crunchyroll.
- Crunchyroll just kicked
off a new slate of anime
for the summer season.
Not only will the service
host continuing classics
like "Boruto," "My Hero
Academia," and "One Piece,"
but this season is stacked with the return
of popular series like "Miss
Kobayashi's Dragon Maid S,"
"Tokyo Revengers," "To Your Eternity,"
and "That Time I Got
Reincarnated as a Slime!"
- And don't forget, you can
binge watch all the episodes
of the incredible "Odd Taxi," right now!
(Joey screams)
I've already talked about it many times,
but if you're looking for another show,
I highly recommend the second season
of "That Time I Got
Reincarnated as a Slime."
Season two is popping off
and you need to watch it right now!
- Way to plug your own video.
(boys laughing)
- But guys, shut up!
Did you know there's new
titles airing the season?
- No!
- No way!
- You won't believe it.
Some of the top picks
include "Peach Boy Riverside"
now airing.
- What?
- "The Great Jahy Will Not Be Defeated!"
- I love that one.
- And "Fena: Pirate Princess,"
and the new trailer just dropped!
- You can watch all these titles for free
or try a 14 day free trial
of premium membership,
to skip all the ads and access
simulcasting with Japan.
Just follow the link in the description
to start watching Crunchyroll now.
- And, the guests that we have on today
voices in some of the titles
that you can find on Crunchyroll.
- Just follow the link
in the description below
to start watching on
Crunchyroll, back to the episode.
- So how did you feel
getting your first role?
Or how was that feeling
when you were just like,
"Man, I'm actually like
achieving my dream right now."
- Well, we had an
audition to get that role.
And I knew that it was like
an English-speaking character.
and like the audition was like,
you had to speak in English.
- Right.
- Just anything in English.
And so yeah, there was like other people
that were like auditioning as well.
And I was like, I'm the one that's like,
that can talk English the best.
(everyone laughing)
- Excuse me, are you
(speaking in Japanese)?
I don't think so, I don't think so.
- Yes, I was like, "Oh,
if I don't get this role,
I'm gonna like, maybe this is not for me."
(everyone laughing)
- You're at like a clear
advantage right there.
- But-
- You just turned up and
you're like, "I've got this,
I've got this."
(everyone laughing)
- But then yeah, like when
I heard that I got the role,
I was like super happy because, obviously,
not many people who are still
in school get a job, you know?
And you know, a lot of people,
even after they like
graduate, they don't get
jobs, right?
- Yeah.
- So I was like-
- So just like normal university then?
- Yeah, yeah, oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so like, yeah, I was
like, I was super happy
'cause I like, 'cause my
first job was "KanKore,"
like "Kantai Collection, KanKore,"
and that was like a huge game, as well.
So yeah, I was just like,
My first job is "KanKore."
Like, oh, like, oh my God, really?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, that's so cool.
I mean, did your like, parents
find out about it, too?
Like did you tell them or?
- I told them, but they're
not really like into anime
and stuff so they're like, Oh really?
That's nice.
- My parents are like that as well, yeah.
- They're like, "Enjoy it while it lasts."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Wait, so how do your parents feel
about what you do now, then?
- Well, now they're like more accepting
and they're kinda like-
- Yeah, because they're starting
to see like the results.
- When you get a stable income,
parents are always like,
"All right, maybe this
isn't too bad after all.
This thing makes money."
- Yeah, that's literally what it was like
for my parents as well
'cause they were like,
when I was still doing
it at home, during uni,
the whole YouTube thing, they were like,
"Have fun with that while it lasts."
It's like, "That's a good
paying hobby you got there."
And then, when my dad was like,
"You make more than I do per month,"
that's when he was finally
like, "I'll allow it."
(Shu and Garnt laughing)
Yeah, it's like, cool, thanks, Dad.
- Like do your parents know
kind of what you do now?
Do they understand at least what you do?
- Yeah, like my sister,
she kind of shows what I do
to my parents.
- Right.
- So like, yeah, they
kinda now know what I do.
- That's good, that's good.
- Do they that thing where
like, "Wait, this is you?"
- Yeah, they do, yeah!
- My parents, they don't believe it.
They're like, "No way that's you,
you don't sound like that,
I've never that voice before."
- Yeah.
- Like I remember when I first like,
tried to explain what my
job to my parents was like,
"What are you, how would
you make money off of this?
I don't understand this YouTube thing."
And then like, cut to
like three years later,
my dad like phones me up and being like,
"I was checking your Social Blade
and your last video seems
to be underperforming there, Garnt.
What's going on with that?
What's going on?"
- It's that transition
from not knowing anything,
not caring to know anything,
to suddenly being like an analyst, right?
- Yeah!
I'm like, "You gained 100 less subscribers
than on average for this
day, what's going on?
Are you paying enough attention?"
- See, that's like still cute though,
because like my parents
are definitely not that.
Like I think my parents are kind of,
they went from not knowing or caring,
to kinda being like caring,
but still not really knowing.
Like I think, when I asked my dad like
what he thinks about what I do for a job,
he was just like,
"Oh, I don't support it,
I just let you do it."
- I mean, but like YouTubers,
I guess it's really hard
to explain to your parents
like what kind of job it is.
- True, true, true, yeah.
- Yeah, right?
I guess for a voice actor,
you can just say I'm an actor.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You can just show
them a clip and be like,
"That me, that me, I did that."
(all laughing)
- It me, it me!
- That me, I did that.
- Sometimes, I wished I just reviewed food
so I could explain it easy
to people and be like,
"Yeah, I just eat, that's it."
But I'm like, "Well, I don't really know."
- I literally have to,
my grandma to this day
still thinks I'm a comedian.
'Cause that's the only way I
can explain it to my grandma.
It's like, yeah, your
grandson is a comedian.
- Sounds good.
- That's just not on TV, and she's like,
"Oh wow, okay, very good, sweet."
- I gotta ask, going back to
like the Saturday school thing
and the small community, I gotta ask,
did all your parents
know each other, as well?
Is that an Asian thing or?
- I mean, think a lot of the
parents did know each other,
but I think that was only really like,
if you kind of grew up with that kid-
- Yeah.
- Right.
From a really, really young age.
Because like we had a lot
of like, childhood friends
that I would grow up with that eventually
would like do the same sports activities,
or do the same, you know, or
go to the same Saturday school,
or just go to the same primary
or high school, whatever.
But like, I didn't really know her sister
or her, or Shu all that much,
to the point where our
parents knew each other.
- [Shu] Yeah, yeah.
- Like, we had mutual like parent friends-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But yeah, I don't think
it ever got to that way.
- Yeah, because I just asked,
'cause I obviously didn't
go to Sunday school,
but this is how-
- It's Saturday school, first of all.
- Sorry, Saturday school, I'm
sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- They don't pray, okay?
- We don't pray!
- It's weekend school,
I'm just gonna call it weekend school.
- Ladies and gentlemen, The Weeknd.
(everyone laughing)
- Let me tell you how socializing worked
in like the Thai community
when I was growing up.
- Sure.
- 'Cause we didn't have
a weekend school.
- Right.
- So, like every Thai parent
would, for some reason,
know each other within like
a fucking 50 mile radius
and they'd hang out and they were like,
"Your kid, your kid, you're
like within the same age,
socialize and now make friends.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Right.
And that was basically how I knew
all the kids in like, my area.
And is it the same in Japan, as well?
Where you refer to each other as like,
kinda like brother-sister,
or like cousins, or like--
- I feel that's very much
a Southeast Asian thing.
- Okay, okay.
So, it was really confusing,
explaining this to Sydney
because I would introduce
Sydney to like a family friend,
but I would introduce them as a cousin.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh.
- And I would introduce my
actual cousins as cousins.
So Southeast Asian, like family trees,
are just a fucking mess,
'cause we call everyone
brother, sister, or cousins, okay?
- Everyone's related.
- Everyone's family, okay?
- I can't relate to any
of these discussions.
This is not me.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- So like, when you like
refer to your cousins, right?
Do you say like the cousin that's not in,
that's not like-
- The blood related cousin.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- No, no, there's no distinction,
we just call them cousin, cousin.
And then I have to, and
then Sydney is just like,
so when they're over, I
introduce a new cousin.
So she's just like, Is
this a cousin-cousin
or just a cousin?
I'm just like, It's a real cousin.
But they're all real cousins.
(Shu and Garnt laughing)
- That's like the white people equivalent
of calling everyone your
uncle or aunt, right?
- I guess so, yeah.
- They're like, "Oh, this is your uncle."
And I found out they weren't my uncle
and I was like, what?
(everyone laughing)
Why did you lie?
- I mean, yeah, like my Australian
side definitely had that,
where like my dad's
friends would be my uncles,
or like, you know, my, you know.
But I don't think Japanese
don't really do that.
- Do they?
- No, I don't think so.
Yeah, yeah.
- I feel, because like
in Japan especially,
like the concept of family
is very much like closed
off in a lot of senses,
where it's like,
you really have to be
like, part of the family
in order to be considered a family member.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
It's not like an Italian
like, "Hey, brother!"
(Shu and Garnt laughing)
It's not anything like that,
or like the whole cousin thing.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause like--
- I just can't get over it.
Meilyne just held up a
sign that just said incest.
- What?
(everyone laughing)
- Meilyne, what is that?
- Why are you holding up
a sign that says incest?
- [Meilyne] Because if
you kiss your cousin,
how do you know it's not your real cousin?
- Oh, is that where Garnt's obsession for-
- No, no, for fuck's sake.
(everyone laughing)
- Anyway, no but like, no.
- I was so taken off guard by that.
Who just holds up a sign that says incest?
What?
Guys, that's the incest cue.
What is that?
- Meilyne, we got a guest on today.
- Jesus.
- Sorry about this, Shu.
- The show is definitely a great show.
- You're tainting an
innocent mind over here.
(Shu and Garnt laughing)
No, but I don't think the
Japanese side really had that.
Like, it was like,
- I don't think so, yeah.
- it's a childhood friend
and that's like the extent it goes.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
- But I feel like, yeah, definitely.
Like, it's not like we
couldn't make friends
later on in life,
but I feel like a lot of
the friends you did make,
especially in Sydney, with
the Japanese community,
a lot of it was very
heavily rooted in like,
how long have you known
this person for kinda thing.
- Is that why there're so many
childhood friend characters in anime?
- Yeah!
- I just gotta ask it, man.
- Because we pull
through in real life, we-
- I was the one thinking about it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I mean like, if your friends
since like four, when you're
like four years of age,
you like stay friends for like forever.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Kind of thing, yeah.
- Yeah, I did get that
about like Japanese culture.
It's like, I got the impression that
there's like different
levels of friendship
within Japanese culture,
and it's very hard to like,
penetrate like the deeper
level, unless you've known them
for like a very, very long time.
- Why did you say penetrate?
- I don't know, okay?
- It's such an odd choice of words.
- That was such a hard P as well.
- You were in on that.
- Penetrate!
- Oh my gosh!
No wonder they never let you in.
(everyone laughing)
- I don't want anything
penetrating, thank you very much.
No, but definitely like that whole trope
of like the Osananajimi or like the-
- Stop laughing, Connor.
- I just can't believe it.
What's this choice of
words going on today, what?
(Shu and Garnt laughing)
- No, but like really,
like that whole like
Osananajimi trope in
anime, I feel is very,
it's like rooted in
reality in a lot of ways.
Because you know, a lot of my
Japanese friends to this day,
from Australia, are guys
and girls I've known
since I was just, like
less than one-year-old.
Or like-
- Less than one-year-old?
- No, like dead ass, like-
- It is true.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because like, at least with my mom,
how I got to know a lot of
them was that, because again,
like the Japanese community was so small.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- The moms would go to like
these like, mom-friend groups,
where like moms that
had kids of similar ages
would come together.
- Right.
- So like naturally you'd,
at the age of like six months to anywhere-
- Hops out the vagina, it's like,
"Son, let me introduce
you to your best friend."
(everyone laughing)
- What is this?
Why are you saying these
oddly descriptive words today?
- No, legit though, it
pretty much is like that.
- Oo, words.
- I'm sorry.
(Shu and Garnt laughing)
- You could've said pops
out, you didn't have to add.
(everyone laughing)
What's going on today?
- Yeah, yeah, don't.
(Shu laughing)
- Like dead ass, like pop-out the vag,
before I see my own father, it's like,
"He's your best friend."
- Yeah.
- It's like that.
But like my oldest friend,
my oldest childhood friend
to this day, who's also
half-Japanese, half-Australian,
who lives here now, I met
before I could even walk.
So like, it's crazy to
think that I'm 26 now
and I've dead ass known him
for 26 years of my life.
- Whoa.
- Yeah.
- So literally, when you say,
"I've known him my entire life,"
you really fucking mean it.
- I've literally known him my entire life.
There is six months of my
life that I didn't know him.
(everyone laughing)
- So you feel quite strongly then,
towards someone even if you
don't speak to them, even if,
just because you grew up with them?
- I feel it's like one of
those like, concepts of like,
it's the type of friends
where you're like,
I don't have to text you every day to know
that I'm your friend, right?
- I guess to me it's more like,
"Oh cool, how are you doing?"
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But it's one of those
friends where you're like,
you don't text for a year or something?
- Yeah, yeah.
- But you can casually, still be like,
"So we're going to dinner?"
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know, it's like one
of those friends, right?
- I think if my friend
messaged me and was like,
and I haven't spoke to them in like years,
and they were like, "Hey,
can I stay at your place
for X amount of time?"
If it's like one day, I'm like, I guess.
But if I haven't really
spoke to them, I'll be like,
"What if they're crazy?"
(everyone laughing)
What if they've gone through things?
- I feel though-
- What if they just don't leave?
- I feel though, like you would know
about that in some way, right?
- Yes.
- Especially because like, for us,
the parents were also involved
in this friendship, right?
- [Shu] Yeah, that's true, yeah.
- So it's like, I know my friends,
like my childhood friend's parents,
just as well as I know the friend, right?
Because it's kinda like, I
guess that's the only like,
whole auntie and uncle or
like cousin aspect to it,
where it's like your
childhood parents, oh sorry,
your childhood friend's parents
are kinda like your uncle or
your aunt in a lot of aspects.
Was that the same for you, as well?
- That was the same for me, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it's like--
- Can't relate.
- Yeah, it's weird.
Now that I think about
it and talk about it,
it's a really weird concept.
- It is, yeah, yeah.
- I'm envious that you
can have just friends for,
just like for free.
- Yeah.
- [Shu and Joey] For free.
- No work put in.
Just born, just talk.
- No payroll.
- It's almost like an arranged friendship.
Like, your parents both agree?
Yes, our children can be friends, right?
- Honestly, it is pretty much like that.
- The thing I get from
my childhood friends
are just fucking "Farmville"
invites on Facebook,
they just drive me up the wall.
I'm like, fuck off, stop.
- Well because like, a lot
of, and I feel as well like,
how strong of a bond you form
with your childhood friend
depends on how close you
are or like the same types
of activities that you
did growing up or like,
did you also go to that fucking
swimming school in Sydney?
- I was about to, but-
- The one in Kilarni?
- Yeah.
- See, she knows.
- What did you guys just go
through your childhood, just?
(everyone laughing)
- She knows.
- I was about to, but
my parents were like,
"Oh, it's too far away,"
and so, we didn't go.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so because there was
this one, like swimming school,
that like all the Asians would go to.
- [Shu and Garnt] Yeah.
- And that's also how I kind of rekindled
with a lot of like, my childhood friends
that I met when I was a baby.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it was like,
oh, the parent that I met
during this like, mom circle,
also takes their kid
to the swimming school.
And I've been thinking to
take my son or daughter
to the swimming school, so
I'll just go to the same one
that I know all the parents at.
So that's like, so again, I feel like,
that community is so bonded tightly that,
it'd be like, oh, if that
parent is doing this thing,
I'll send my kids there, as well.
- You could say your family.
(everyone laughing)
- Vin Diesel meme.
- Cue "Fast and Furious," please.
- Cue Vin Diesel meme.
Which might be dead by
the time this comes out.
- By the time this comes
out, it'll probably be like
very outdated.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I'm curious, obviously, you mentioned
that you are very passionate
about it from a young age.
But obviously, when you're
not in school before that,
there's only so many ways
you can, I guess, practice
or get experience so what
did you do before that
to kind of get practice?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I was just
doing it from my bedroom,
just online,
- Oh, same, same.
- With like a shitty microphone.
- Same.
- Really?
- I was like, yeah, yeah.
So like, I bought like a
really bad, shitty microphone.
- Yeah, me too.
- And then at home I'll
be recording my own voice
and like hearing it again
and then recording it again.
And 'cause like now, like voice acting,
you have to be able to
like sing well, as well.
- Yeah, yeah.
- In Japan?
- Yeah, in Japan.
- What?
- In Japan, yeah.
- Like, you have to-
- I'm fucked.
- Yeah, like you have to
like dance as well, right?
So like-
- Voice actresses especially-
- Dance?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, voice actors and
actresses at this day and age
are basically idols.
- Wow, it's like totally
different in like the West.
- Yeah, yeah.
Like, you have to like,
you're in magazines,
like you have to look good like, visually.
- Well, I guess that's why, like again,
the competition is so intense, right?
Yeah, like you said, the more idols,
they're always on TV, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
And so yeah, like, in Australia,
they don't have much karaokes,
- No.
- Like, yeah.
And so-
- There was one really
like, crappy karaoke.
- [Shu] Yeah, yeah, I
think I know which one!
But it was the closest thing
we got to the Japanese style
because like karaoke in Australia
is a lot like in America
where it's like all open mic.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like, that's not karaoke.
- That's always been weird to me.
- That's not karaoke,
that's public embarrassment.
- I love that.
- I love that, it's great.
- I hate it.
- Yeah, I don't like it, too.
- I hate it, I hate it.
- It makes my night when someone
just, godawful starts it.
'Cause I'm like, that, guy's great.
That guy went up there
knowing he'd butcher the song
but he did it anyway.
- No, but like,
what if the opposite happens, right?
What if like the person before you sings,
like fucking amazingly,
and then you're like,
"Oh shit, I have to go
up and do "Sexy Back."
The fuck.
- Fuck it.
Let me go, let me go, I'll do it.
- Look, if I'm gonna embarrass myself,
at least I can just embarrass myself
in front of my friends, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's the way I think about it, yeah.
That's why, like the concept
of going to karaoke sober
is just non-existent in
Western countries, right?
Because you're not gonna
go up and sing on stage,
in front of strangers, if
you're not intoxicated,
unless you're just an amazing singer.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- We do that here, too.
- Yeah.
- But,
so what, so you had to
learn how to sing as well
or you already sang?
- Well, I practiced
singing from my bedroom.
- Yeah.
- As everyone does.
- As you do.
- But that was really
embarrassing 'cause my parents
were against me doing voice acting, right?
- "Stop singing!"
- Yeah, yeah.
They'll be kinda like,
"Oh yeah, you can go sing in your room."
But obviously, because it's not
like soundproof or anything.
I'm like, my really bad singing is like,
resonating throughout
the whole like house, so-
- So you're practicing dancing as well,
when you were like a teenager?
- No, like I didn't
really practice dancing
'cause I was more into
like singing and acting.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right.
- But, yeah.
- I'm not much of a dancer myself, either.
- Well you're white.
- It's really hard.
(everyone laughing)
- That is true.
- Yeah, so with the voice acting school,
did they teach you any
of these other aspects
of being a voice actress?
Or was it just purely the voice part?
- The school that I went to was
just purely voice acting.
- Right.
- But I know like some schools
teach you singing and dancing, as well.
- Right, right.
- Especially like,
you know how I said that
there was like schools
where you have to go like
five times a week?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, those are-
- Five times, you're like
eight hours a day or like?
- I'm not really sure, but-
- I assume not, like you
have to live somehow.
- I think when I watched
the video about it,
it was something like,
they just go in the
evening after their job.
Like a lot of people
would do that in Japan.
They think that's normal.
- That sounds about right.
- Yeah.
There's a lot of different, like,
it always depends on the school.
- [Connor] Yeah, true, true.
- But yeah, some schools teach that.
- So what type of voice
acting were you doing
in your bedroom when you're like 15, 16?
- Well, I was kind of
like copying characters.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Like-
- I feel it always starts
with like impersonation.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Fandubs and stuff.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Who did you impersonate?
(Shu laughing)
- I impersonated a lot.
Wait, let me just think.
- Who did you impersonate
other than the obvious ones?
- "League of Legends" characters.
Did you know how I know that?
'Cause that's what he sent
in for my audition reel.
- [Connor] There you go.
- A "League of Legends"
characters audition reel.
- It's that good.
And I got the job, I did not.
(everyone laughing)
- No, I don't know, I
just copied everything.
And I would do weird stuff
for people who wanted,
'cause someone has to voice act
these terrible stuff online.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah
- Like "Sims" projects and stuff.
People just make "Sims" animations.
- Oh, "Sims."
- With "Sims."
And I would just have to do
the voice and I hated it.
But I was like, well, I wanna voice act,
but I don't like the project.
- 50 bucks is 50 bucks, right?
- I didn't get paid, are you kidding me?
No one got paid!
I was using like a headset
microphone, it sounded like,
(Connor imitating static)
it's terrible but you love doing it,
so you just keep doing it.
- Yeah, of course, of course.
- Until you can buy a good microphone.
And even then you're like,
"Google, how do I remove static?
Loud static, how to remove?"
- Did you do that?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Your dusty noise-canceling function.
- It's terrible, it doesn't work at all.
- Yeah, 'cause like back
when I was like newly
into the anime community, there was a big,
like online voice acting community,
when I first got into the anime community.
- Oh, right, right.
- Was that still a thing
when you were trying
to be a voice actress?
- No, I don't think so.
- Really?
- So yeah, does Japan not
have like an online scene
for voice acting where they
just voice act in stuff online?
- I think some people do
like voice act online,
and some people actually
like voice act on Niconico.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But I didn't really participate in that
'cause I was kinda like, oh, like.
Well, when I was in Australia,
my Japanese wasn't as fluent.
Like it was really like,
it sounded like an Australian
was talking in Japanese.
- Yeah, I get that.
- And so I was like, oo, like,
I don't have much confidence
so I kind of practice
more from home.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I was like, I was copying Hanekawa
from "Bakemonogatari."
- Nice.
- Yeah, and all those kind of practice.
I was practicing animals too, like-
- Animals?
(Shu and Garnt laughing)
- So you tried to get the
animal roles, as well?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean on the-
- I just imagined practicing
animals, you shouting at a dog.
(Connor barking)
- Yeah, like 'cause on
the internet they're like,
it's important as a Japanese
voice actor to be able
to voice act animals as well.
- Do you have to audition
for animal roles?
- For me, it was kinda like,
I already had it in my voice reel, and so-
(Garnt laughing)
- You're the go-to, you're the go-to.
- And so yeah, they
picked me from there but-
- Wait, like what kind of animals?
Like just dogs, cats?
- Like dogs, cats, yeah.
- I guess that's the majority,
right?
- And birds.
- Wait, I'm so curious,
what was your process
in like, practicing for that?
- I'll just like endlessly
watch animals on YouTube,
and then I'll kinda like copy the animal.
Yeah, and that was what I did.
- There's people who have demo reels
for like monster-creature demo reels.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, yeah.
- Or just like monster noises.
- Yeah.
- And like weird sounds that
human bodies shouldn't make.
- I guess someone's
gotta voice them, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, exactly.
I mean, there's probably
a demand for that.
Like there's always shit
that needs growling.
- Can you do some animal voices right now?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
A Dog?
- Yeah.
(Shu barking)
- That's very loud.
- I'm sorry.
- It's very loud.
- Sorry.
- No, it's fine.
I just wasn't expecting it,
it was great, it was great.
- It was great, it was great.
- Oh my god.
- I can do a cat as well.
- Okay, do it.
(Shu meowing)
- That's a cat.
- That's pretty fucking good.
- That's pretty good.
(Shu laughing)
- That's really good.
- Well, I mean, if we said it was shit.
(everyone laughing)
Nah, it doesn't sound like a cat.
Why would they hire you?
- We'll just send you a
passive-aggressive letter later.
Just being like, it wasn't very good.
- You'll receive a letter in your post.
- I wonder if there's like
any viewers watching right now
who has a cat in the
background who just like.
(Shu laughing)
- [Joey] Yeah, right.
- Who's throwing hands?
Who's throwing hands?
- The dog is just losing it.
(everyone laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's so cool.
- This video is sponsored by Manscaped.
- The sun's out, bums are out,
and hopefully your pubes are not out.
Also, flip-flop season is upon us
and you're out here with
those post pandemic toenails?
Don't worry, our friends at
Manscaped have you covered.
They just launched their fourth generation
Performance Package and The
Shears TM 2.0 Nail Grooming Kit.
Join the Manscaped movement
by going to manscaped.com/trashtaste
for 20% off,
plus free shipping.
- I was this close, gentlemen,
to making my balls no more,
but that could have been
avoided if I had Manscaped
that one time, when I was younger.
But thank God I can buy it now.
- The Performance Package 4.0 includes
the new Lawn Mower 4.0.
This trimmer will change the way
you approach your grooming routine.
- Texas, don't worry.
If that power goes out again,
you can still use the Lawn Mower 4.0,
because it's powered by
batteries and has its own LED.
- One of the most important aspects
is that this trimmer is waterproof!
(Joey gasping)
So you can trim
in the shower with ease.
I'm gonna say that again.
- That pause was so dramatic.
So, get 20% off plus free shipping
by going to manscaped.com/trashtaste.
That's 20% off plus free shipping
at manscaped.com/trashtaste.
Tame the summer swamp in
your pants with Manscaped TM.
- Back to the episode.
- Your balls will thank you.
- So, I'm assuming it's
gonna be different,
but what is the process like
in voice acting in Japan for auditioning.
- For auditions, well the
auditions come to your agency,
and then the agency will pick someone
that's suitable for the role,
and there'll be like,
there's like two stages.
There's like tape audition,
and there's a studio audition.
And tape audition is where
you just send your voice
in to the people who make the anime,
and stage audition is when
you actually go in front
of all the directors and like
the people who make the anime,
if that makes sense.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- So how many people
will be there, normally?
- Depends on like the anime,
but I don't know.
Like sometimes there's only
like 25, 20, five, 10, 20.
- Only 20?
What?
- Sometimes there's
like more, there's like-
- What?
- Yeah.
- Wait this is the staff, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 20 staff members?
- Oh, no, no.
Oh, you mean staff members?
- Yeah, sorry.
- I was gonna say, I was like-
- Staff members, it depends.
But sometimes it's like-
- It's like before the
artist, just stand there.
She's got a good voice.
- Not gonna mention the accent.
- But sometimes, there's like around,
usually, there's around five people,
but sometimes, there could be like 10
or like maybe even more.
- Wow, like judging and like?
- Judging, yeah.
- Wow.
And then there's about
20 to 30 auditioning?
- Yeah.
- Is that for one character or?
- Yeah, sometimes for one character.
Like sometimes, the
anime people they'll take
like a whole day auditioning,
like several characters.
And, this was like pre-COVID.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But yeah, there'll be like,
there'll always be like people waiting
in the waiting room and then-
- Oh God, you're all like,
"Oh yeah, you're going for the part, too?"
- [Shu] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Before you walk in, you just.
(everyone laughing)
- And it's like, because they're
holding the scripts, right?
And they're kinda like
practicing it in their mind-
- Is there like big tension in the room?
- Yeah, there is.
- Oh!
- It's like super quiet.
(boys groaning)
- That's so nerve-wracking!
- Yeah, and you see someone holding
the same script as you
are, and you're like.
(everyone laughing)
- You know, 'cause there's like people
in movies like, "I'm gonna get it,"
like people who turn up really cocky, too.
Is anyone ever like that?
Who's like, "I've got this, go home."
- No, because even like the
really famous voice actors,
they audition to get the
same, like the roles, as well.
- So, you might turn up
and they might be like,
a triple A--
- Yeah.
- Oh my god, that's terrifying
- But, the good thing
about this job is that,
it's not always-
- Guaranteed.
- Them that get the job, right?
It's like the person who suits the voice,
like the character best.
So yeah, it is really
nerve-wracking though,
when they're like in front of you
and they're like practicing their script,
then you're like-
- Oh, I see.
You've been in a situation
where you were in like,
auditioning for the same role
as a massive voice actor.
- Yeah, yeah.
(boys exclaiming)
- That's so scary.
(Shu and Garnt laughing)
- And it's like, it's so
nerve-wracking just to like act
in front of like all the staff
members making the anime.
And then there's like this huge like,
someone you've known since like ages ago
and like someone-
- You're probably a fan of.
- [Shu and Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Like you've had like posters
of them up on your room
or something like that, right?
- Yeah.
- So yeah, it's really
nerve-wracking and yeah.
- That's like so different
from how they do it
in like the English anime.
- Oh, really?
- Because when they're dubbed,
they have to be dubbed like pretty fast.
- Right.
- So they can't like,
they never hold open auditions.
It's been a very, very long time.
I think, they'll be like,
"Hey, we know that you're good
at what you do, try for this character."
And you just recorded an
audio clip and send it in.
And that's it, there's
no like another one.
Sometimes there is, but it
really depends on the thing.
- Wow.
- It's really fast.
That's why there's
normally like less actors,
I guess, compared to Japan
because it's normally,
you have to be kind of
established to get a chance.
It's kind of difficult.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- How many auditions do
you have to go through?
Or like for different series
before you normally land a single role?
- Well, in the industry
they say like auditions,
it's like normal to like,
not pass in audition.
So like, they say if
you take 50 auditions,
if you get into one, then that's like,
like you're still on the good side.
- Jesus.
- You're still
on the lucky side, you know.
- I heard it's like 40:1.
As the ratio.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Far out.
I suppose if you're like,
competing against 20
other voice actresses.
- Some people just spend
all day from their home,
just on like voices.com,
sending in like fucking hundreds, all day.
Drives me insane.
- And yeah, it's really like, 'cause like,
when you get the audition,
you wanna know more about the character,
and you wanna know more about the manga
or like, whatever it's based on.
So like, you read all these manga
and you take your time like,
understanding the character
and stuff like that.
And so yeah, it's like,
when you don't pass,
it's like, oh, I didn't like pass it.
- Yes, sometimes I try
not to get too invested
because I feel that if
I've read the manga,
and I feel like I know this
character, I can do it.
Why didn't I get it!
And then you've got to go to the next one.
And it's, you know,
actually quite difficult.
So how do you kind of keep
that detachment level there?
- Well at first, I was
like, I felt really down
when I didn't pass-
- Of course.
- Yeah.
But then now it's kinda
like, you need to take, like,
you just keep like dropping,
like, not passing.
- It's like, understandable.
Have a nice day.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You've just gotta grow
a thick skin, I suppose.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Just to like,
it's nothing personal, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Nothing personal, kid.
(all laughing)
- So you mentioned, obviously,
that's not the normal process right now
because of COVID.
- Yes.
How is it different now because of COVID?
- They used to, you know how I said
that they used to like call in
people for studio auditions?
Now it's more like,
you have the tape additions
and you get chosen from there,
or they choose someone they're like,
they don't have auditions at all.
And it's kind of like, they
already choose someone to-
- Oh it's like, we want you
to voice this character.
Will you take it, kinda thing.
- Yeah.
- But you have to send another tape still?
- It depends on the-
- Oh, so they just, they're
just scouting now, then?
- Yeah, sometimes they just scout you.
Sometimes you have auditions.
And when they do have studio auditions,
it's more like you're
brought in one by one.
So it's like, you know.
- So there's no like the,
there's no stand-off anymore?
- Yeah, there's no thing thing, yeah.
- I feel that's better for
mental health of voice actors.
- Probably, probably.
- But that normally doesn't
give a lot of chance for,
I guess, new talent to-
- True, true.
- Get seen 'cause you, I mean,
that's how they get seen, right?
If you have to be established or scouted,
it's quite difficult to get seen.
- Yeah, like how does that work
for like the English side of things?
'Cause it's like, it
sounds fuckin' impossible
for like new talents to get noticed.
- [Shu] Yeah.
- I mean, you have, normally,
you have to be recommended.
Like someone would be like-
- It's just who you know, kind of thing.
- I mean, it's sad, but yeah, kind of.
I mean, you know, there is ways,
but normally it is through recommendations
and someone will be like, "Hey,
I need this kind of voice.
Does anyone know someone who can do this?"
So like I got recommended to stuff
just 'cause they were
like, we need British.
Because obviously since COVID,
a lot of anime dubs now,
the ones that are airing,
like weeks after-
- Right.
- Are done all online.
- Oh wow, really?
- There's quite a few, actually,
have been done just from home studios.
- So they just record at home?
- At home, yeah.
- Wow, wow.
- But you have to have like
a good internet connection
and you have to have a sound treated room.
- Right.
- Which, I think,
when COVID hit a lot of the big,
more established voice actors,
just you can order those like,
they have them in Japan as well,
the home office booths.
- Oh, one of those things.
- Oh, yeah, the small like--
- [Garnt] Like the sound proof-
- It's like a tiny, it's horrible to,
because you get so hot and
you can't have the AC on,
obviously, 'cause you're
in this tiny room,
you're like sweating on a call.
And then as soon as you get
screaming, it's like terrible.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- So yeah, yeah a lot of it now,
especially now, it's quite
bad for like discoverability.
Yeah, you kind of have
to have recommendations.
- Yeah.
- But I, yeah, you can
audition for stuff still.
But again, to get the auditions,
you have to be recommended.
- Yeah, it's it's about
who you know, I guess.
- [Shu] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- That's tough.
- So in Japan, to even be
considered for an audition,
do have to have formal training
or they won't allow you?
- No, not necessarily.
It's like most of the time
you have to be in an agency.
So like, just like to get into the agency,
obviously they look at people
who have good acting skills, right?
So people in an agency would have like
the basic acting skills.
- Yeah, yeah, normally.
- From-
- The agent wouldn't sign you.
Right, they wouldn't go, "I
guess we can get you work."
- And then so yeah, like the manager picks
who they want to-
- Manage?
- Let, yeah.
- Yeah, so the manager picks
who they want to put forward
for the additions?
- Yeah, yeah.
- They'll be like, "Hey
we need these voices.
Oh, okay, I think these
guys are good, take 'em."
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So like what's the daily life of like,
a Japanese voice actress?
And do you do more roles than auditions?
Or like, how's the balance going?
- It's like, you do auditions, true.
But like, once you start
getting the hang of your job,
it's kinda like you have like recordings
for like, games and other stuff
that you did from awhile ago.
So just like continuous
recordings and stuff like that.
And so, yeah.
It's like you do auditions,
but at the same time you have
like continuous recordings.
- Yeah, so once you establish
yourself, it's a lot easier
because you got a lot
more stuff going on then?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay. Okay.
- How was it like, 'cause
I've done the whole,
it's called afureko in Japanese,
but like the recording session.
I guess that's one massive difference
between the West and Japan,
is that in the West, it's one at a time.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] Whereas in
Japan, it's altogether,
all at once, right?
- Yeah.
- You've probably done it
next to some pretty notable people.
- Yeah, yeah, it's pretty crazy.
- And how is that?
- Like, well, it's really nerve-wracking.
'Cause like now they record
it a little bit differently,
but before they used
to have like 30 people,
20 to 30 people in like a room in a studio
and you will be kind
of recording the anime
at the same time.
And so there'll usually
be like four microphones
and all the actors will
be using that microphone,
like between each other.
- Yeah.
- And so obviously, if like
someone who's bigger than you,
like you'll senpai, is using a mic,
you can't like barge in
and like, use that mic.
So you know.
- My turn!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Let me show you, old timer.
- Yeah, so you have to like look out
for your senpais, as well.
And you have to like
act properly, as well.
and-
- That sounds so stressful.
Oh my God.
- Yeah.
- I just wanna work.
- Just relax.
- But it's so cool
when like a bunch of like
super established voice actors
are doing it 'cause like there's,
I think there's this
really famous YouTube video
of like all the main voice
actors for "One Piece."
- Ah yeah.
- Doing a seen where
all of the Straw Hat Crew
is like talking in a scene.
And they're just so fluidly
switching between microphones,
when roles come up and stuff.
Because like, what I did as well,
is that like, just because
you're not on the microphone,
it doesn't mean you're not acting
because a lot of the times people
who aren't on the microphone are used
for like crowd noises.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Or just passersby and stuff like that.
And it's like, so you're
constantly just being recorded.
- That's good to have that energy, right,
as well, when you're trying to act?
To have someone kind of providing
the feel of the scene to you, you know?
- Yeah.
- I feel like that's why "KonoSuba,"
especially, worked really
well because you hear like,
you hear the original Japanese dub of it
and it kind of like, you
can tell that the actors
and actresses are just
bouncing off each other
really naturally.
- Right.
- And it's like hard to tell,
it's actually some points
where it's hard to tell
if it's actually scripted
or just like completely
improvised sometimes.
- They used to do a lot more
for English productions,
but scheduling is a nightmare.
- Yeah.
- And traveling.
For stuff like, you know,
like a Disney movie,
if you have like all these AAA actors,
it's impossible to get them all
in the same room at the same time.
But some movies and
some shows still do it.
It used to be a lot more common,
but now it's not really,
it's not that as much.
- Yeah, 'cause I've seen
footage of like "Toy Story"
and stuff like that.
Like all the actors for "Toy Story"
were all in the same room.
- Wow!
- like kinda in a semi-circle
and they all just had like a mic
and like a stand for their script.
- Oh, okay.
- Just all do it all at once.
- It's normally the more
expensive the production,
the more you can do that.
- That makes sense.
- Right, right.
- If you have more money,
you can tell, "Hey, come in, I'll..."
For movies they'll always
do like a table read, right?
The actors will come in
and they'll just practice it together.
Even if they're not recording together.
- Yeah.
- Stuff like that.
- The scary thing is, 'cause like,
once the anime recording
starts, it's like,
you have to like stay silent
even when it's not your turn to speak.
So like, even when
you're reading the script
and you know it's not your turn
and you want to like turn the page over,
you have to be really careful
not to make any sound.
And like-
- Stealth turning page.
- Yeah, and like when you
walk up to the microphone,
you can't make any sound.
So like, even with your clothing,
it has to be something
that doesn't make sound.
So like-
- Oh yeah.
- You can't be wearing like
leather jackets and like that.
- Could you imagine, it's just like?
(Joey imitates squeaking)
Hello!
(all chuckling)
- They used to have a box just
full of really old t-shirts.
- Really?
- At one of the studio's
I worked at, and they were just like,
if you wore anything that wasn't a t-shirt
they were like, put the t-shirt.
- Wow.
- Right.
- That doesn't sound sanitary.
- Well it was, you know.
- Just wearing someone's sweaty t-shirt.
- They washed them.
But it was just like,
"Don't bring anything that isn't a t-shirt
because it makes too much noise."
- Yeah.
- Makes sense.
- And like, don't have keys in your pocket
or anything like that.
Like just empty your pockets.
- I'd hate to be that
guy who just like came on
and was like, "Shit, I
need to sneeze right now."
(all laughing)
- And I feel that like,
the pressure is even greater
because it's like, if you
fuck up a line for instance,
then all the actors are
there to kind of like.
- Yeah, so what happens if
someone flubs their line?
I mean, that happens.
- Well, because we're recording, like,
I think we record like each 15 minutes
of an anime, if that makes sense?
- Yeah.
- So like, if you mess up your line,
you just stay silent and
just back away and then-
- Have you ever done that?
- Yeah.
(boys groaning)
It's so like, it's like-
- Stupid, stupid, stupid.
- I could see like the PTSD in her face
as she was like telling the story.
I was like, oh, she
she's experienced this.
- It's like, if you mess up,
you can't say like, oops,
or anything like that.
You just have to like, stay silent
so the person after you
can say their lines.
And so like once-
- Oh!
So they can just like
cut your part, right?
- Cut it, yeah.
- Oh okay, that makes sense.
- And then they can take it again
after the whole 15 minutes
is like recorded, right?
- Oh yeah.
- So, and it's really hard
because when you first start voice acting,
right, the director tells you like,
"We want that line said
more like this way,"
or like, "In a different
way to what you did."
And if you're not like able to like,
say it like how the director
wants you to say it,
you like, take it again and again.
But you're taking it again and again
right in front of all your senpais.
So like you're taking their time,
and the director's like,
"We want it more like this way."
And you're like, "Okay, I'll try my best."
And so, yeah, it's really-
- That's so nerve-wracking!
- Oh yeah.
- That's, that's like two,
that's like pressure on top of pressure.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- You're already pressured to be like,
I'm gonna nail my line
just so I can put on a good performance.
- It's sort of like the teacher going,
all right, what's the answer?
You, you, you specifically,
what is the answer to this math question?
You don't know?
Come on, you can do it, come on.
Come on, come on.
- We'll all wait until
you figure it out, right?
- Have you ever had the director explain
how they wanted you to
do the line differently,
and you're like, what?
I, that does not make any sense.
- Yeah, when I was
first, like in an anime,
one of the directors told me,
like in Japanese, they said,
(speaking in Japanese)
and yeah.
And I was like, 'cause I was.
- What does that mean?
- It's like-
- (speaking in Japanese) is like,
like soft sword fighting.
- Yeah.
- Oh, okay?
- With like, yeah.
So basically like play sword fighting.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So it's like,
sound more play sword fighting.
- That's so specific.
- Yeah.
And I was like, and at
that time I was like,
I didn't know the word
(speaking in Japanese).
(all chuckling)
- Got you, chief.
- It would be so awkward
to ask the director,
what does (speaking in
Japanese) mean, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I was like,
"Okay, I'll try my best."
And so I asked the person
next to me who was around
the same age as me,
- Yeah.
- like, what's (speaking in Japanese).
And she told me and I was like-
- And it still didn't make any sense.
- Yeah.
- What the fuck does that mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So, what does that mean?
Like, how did you?
- Did you find out what he wanted?
- I'm not sure.
(all laughing)
- To this day, I've wondered
what the take should've been.
- But I got an okay.
So I guess I was able to, you know.
- Was that an okay or was that like, okay.
- Oo, oo.
- Right?
It could be either one, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah there's a, when you're doing lines,
sometimes there's that feeling of like,
you're not getting it, and then you just,
you know personally
you're not gonna get it.
And then they're just
like, "We'll just move on."
And I'm like, no!
- Yeah.
- Why, tell me!
- Yeah, I get that feeling.
- Have you ever like said a
line that you've just been like,
that was an awful take.
And the director's been like, "All right,
we're moving on, that was a good take."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've had that a lot.
- Okay.
- That's why I usually say like, fuck,
at the end of my line if I hated it.
But then they would tell
you to stop saying fuck,
because you're ruining
the line that they liked.
You'd be like, da-da-da-fuck!
Because then you couldn't use it.
- Are you the type of voice actor
that watches the anime that they were in
after it like finishes
and airs and everything?
- Yeah.
- To like look back on?
To kind of learn from?
- Yep.
- 'Cause I cannot do that.
- Really?
- Like I hate hearing
myself in voice acting roles
because I get kind of secondhand
embarrassment from it.
- Right, yeah.
- 'Cause I always,
I'm so harsh on myself all the time.
So when I hear myself on
like a game or an anime,
I'm always like, I could
have done that line
like 10 times better.
Why did they have to use that one?
- Yeah, I know how you feel.
- That's good, though, right?
Like you know that you could improve.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's good, but it's also like,
when people tell me being like,
"Oh, I heard you in the game,"
then I'd be like, I don't
know how I sound in that.
So it's like, I can't even
like talk about the role
that I'm in.
- Yeah.
- Because I just don't know
how it turned out, right?
- But there's a lot of
like big anima voice actors
that are like that, as well.
- Yeah, yeah, it's like,
I mean, like hearing your
own voice after it's like,
'cause like you record it
and it's aired several
months after you've recorded.
So obviously like several months after,
you're kind of like,
you've like brushed up on
your acting a little bit more
than what you had before.
So like hearing again, it's like, oh,
like I didn't say that line properly.
And I'm really strict on myself, as well.
So it's kinda like, I look like (groans),
but then like I think
it's really important
to like kind of look back.
- Reflect?
- Yeah.
- I think the thing that
everyone always says the most
when they try and start
voice acting is like,
they hate their own voice.
They can't stand it.
And it's just a thing you have to like,
I mean, personally, I just
think that if you learn
to like be able to listen to your voice
and not just recoil in disgust,
you can then start breaking
it down and being like,
okay, I didn't do this that well.
Right, you can start really focusing
on what you're doing wrong.
- But isn't it weird that I'm okay
with hearing my own
voice in YouTube videos?
- It's just different.
- Oh, really?
- It's 'cause you've
heard it so many times.
- Because when you're acting,
you're trying to do something
like you're trying to perform.
- Right.
- But YouTube it's just you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Hi, I'm being me I'm being an idiot.
- That's true, that's true.
- It's just life.
- I mean, I feel though in
a lot of my roles, like,
'cause I'm not trained or
anything like that, right.
I just do it 'cause I like it
and I'm given the opportunity.
But like the "Pop Team
Epic" one, for instance.
- Yeah.
- I played a New York mayor.
(all laughing)
- Really?
- And I cannot do a New York accent.
So, dead ass if you watch
like the actual episode that aired,
it's like the most Aussie-sounding
fucking New York Mayor.
- It is, it is.
- I'm the Mayor of New York.
- I just love that idea
that you did the take
and the director was like, "It's perfect."
- Yeah, yeah.
- You're like, "No,
please, please, please."
- Yeah, yeah.
I did it, I did the first take
just thinking like,
we're going to kind of get like a gauge
of like how not good
my New York accent is.
And I actually gave up halfway.
I tried to do like an American accent.
But at that point, especially,
I was like my New York accent,
or my American accent is not that good
where like I can confidently
act in that accent.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like I can try and
speak casually, right.
But acting in another accent
is a completely different set of skills.
So I was like, I'm just gonna
like subtly turn it off.
Like just turn the gauge down
as the recording goes on.
So by the end of it, I was
just like, "Yeah, New York!"
It was like the most
Australian-sounding New York.
- Yeah, I remember seeing
that and I was just like,
I feel like he's about to drop the C-bomb.
'Cause as an Aussie, when's it coming?
When's it coming?
- No, but it was so funny
because like I thought for sure,
I would get some pointers being like,
"All right, you started off good,
but you kind of depleted near the end.
Let's do another take or like,
let's try that line again,"
or something like that.
Fully expecting it.
The director was like,
"All right, you're good!"
- Yeah, but the director
didn't speak English, right?
- No.
- Oh, well, then-
- So he thought I was like
perfect New Yorker accent.
It's like, yeah.
That's that's what all people
in New York sound like.
- I can't blame him, though,
because he doesn't know.
There's no way he'd know, right.
- Yeah, exactly.
- But in Japan, it's like,
when you go to recordings, it's like,
when you talk in English, it's like,
they expect you to speak
in an American accent,
but you know, 'cause
I'm from Australia too.
So it's like, yeah, I try.
- You never practiced your American accent
when you were practicing?
- Well, yeah, like I'm practicing now.
- Okay.
- But it's still really hard
to like, I don't know, like
pronounce all these words.
- American English goes
everything against Australian.
- Yeah, yeah, I know.
I mean, I can't do American accents.
- We have to like contort our faces
in ways that we wouldn't.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Just the rrr sound is so like, ugh.
- Yeah, like card?
Card, card?
- Yeah, card.
Card and--
- Well it like,
the British Australian English,
like the tongue is like
towards the front of the mouth
and in American English it's
like flatter in the back.
And that's like really hard
to do when you're British,
because you're like, why do I
have to force my tongue down.
- You just sound like you're
kind of drowning half the time?
- Yeah, yeah.
I think, you know, mine sounds shit.
Like, I barely can.
- I mean, I'm much better
at it now since then,
because I practiced, but I mean,
I still couldn't confidently do
like an American English role.
But I feel like, I don't know,
just from like watching
the anime recently,
where like we are starting to get more
like English speaking roles
done by actual native people.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I feel like I've noticed like,
I think finally anime
directors and producers
are like, "Different
accents in English exist."
- In Japanese dubs or?
- In Japanese dubs.
- All right.
- But even in the English dubs, as well,
because like a lot of the English dubs
are also overseen by the
original directors and producers.
So it's like, I feel like
they're finally starting
to realize like, "Oh,
we can't just get anyone
who can speak moderately good English.
If we need an American role,
we need to get an
American speaking person."
- Yeah, I did an American
voice for a film.
The one that like Charlie Cr1TiKaL is in?
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was like the killer,
but I wasn't credited!
- You weren't credited?
- Oh really?
- I think they forgot.
I had to tell them, seriously.
- Oh my god.
- So yeah, I was the voice
of their like killer.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it's this like really
raspy, deep, scary voice.
- Like American accent.
- And they were like,
"We want you to do..."
And I'm sitting there, I
remember that we were having the,
I was having the call with the people
who were making this film,
and they were telling me about this role.
And then this has gone
on for like half an hour
and they mentioned, "Oh
yeah, he's American."
And then at the end of it, I
was like, "So like the accent,
I don't know if you
noticed, I'm not American."
(all laughing)
I was like, "So what'd you want me to do?"
And they're like, "Well,
he is an American.
So could you do American?"
And I'm like, "I can,
but it won't be good."
- Right.
- So I did it.
- I feel, though, your American accent
is probably better than most, right?
Because I feel, I don't know.
- When I do deep voices it's easier,
'cause the mouth shape is easier.
But, it's still shit, it's still shit.
- But I feel like--
- You would laugh at me.
- But I feel like a lot of
British actors, for instance,
are usually pretty good at
nailing the American accent.
- There are so many British or just like,
actors not from America
that you don't know
aren't from America until it's outed.
But then you switch, you
swap to the other way around
with Americans doing like British accents.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Right, right.
'Cause like how many people think,
if they watch like "Batman"
for me instance, right?
Like Christian Bale and Gary Oldman,
are both not American.
- Yeah.
- Christian Bale is Welsh, right?
- Yeah Christian Bale is Welsh.
- Wow.
- Right?
- Yeah, I'm pretty sure
he was born in Wales.
- And Gary Oldman is very British.
So it's like, it's just
incredible to think
that a lot of people just don't know.
- Chris Hemsworth, as
well, is like an Aussie.
- Yeah, Chris Hemsworth is an Australian.
- He's the most fucking
Aussie-guy I've ever seen.
- But he nails the American accent.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think, yeah, 'cause they teach,
they train British actors
different to American,
it's a lot different
ways of learning acting.
So I feel like that has
a lot to do with it.
Because like British are more
focused on like stage acting.
- Right!
- Right.
- And learning that aspect of it.
- Like theater training?
- Yeah, yeah.
And being more like classically trained.
So it's a bit different, I don't know.
- And I also feel like if
you're going into acting,
you kind of need to learn
how to do an American accent
because that's where most
films are made, right?
But it's just not the
same, the other way round.
- True.
- I hate doing
an American accent.
You always have to do it for things.
It sucks, I hate it.
Just let me use my British accent.
- Right, just give me like
an Australian character?
- I've never seen an
Australian character before.
- No, me neither.
Wait, the one time where I was like,
oo, I might have a chance
is like, what was it?
"The Free," like was it a movie?
Or like season two.
- Oh yeah!
- It was based in Sydney!
- Yeah, it was, it was.
- And so I was like, I was
waiting for that phone call.
Being like-
- Joey finally made it.
- Is it my time to shine?
- My time to shine.
- My time to shine in
the Australian accent?
Never happened.
- They did it, did they speak,
they spoke English in it, right?
And it was like terrible.
- Yeah, but they get hired
non-Australian actors
and actresses, so I'm like-
- Yeah.
- Missed opportunity there.
- I'm right here.
- Yeah.
- I'm literally right here.
Me and Shu are right here.
- Two people right here.
- What does the author like?
- Just hit up
that fucking Saturday school.
- Yeah, exactly!
(laughing drowns out Garnt)
- What do you think of
the bad English in anime,
as somebody--
- Well,
I know people who who've been
asked to like talk in English
when they're not like,
you know that talented.
- Is the director's just
like, "You should just do it."
- Yeah, they kind of like, well,
they're like try your best, but you know.
And obviously the actors
are trying their best.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I just feel like it's
an unfortunate situation.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's just kind of like, aw.
I guess they had to, but.
- Like a lot of my friends
ask me how to pronounce stuff.
'Cause they're like, I don't know how,
like, they pronounce the
sentence and stuff like that.
So yeah I think it's just really hard
for them to pronounce something
that they're not used to pronouncing.
- Do they ever worry
about how it's perceived
by like a foreign fans?
- Yeah, they do.
They're like, you know, I tried my best,
but it's like, I don't
think it sounds like native.
- Aw.
- I feel bad laughing at
the "Kuroko" no Basuke.
- What the lunchtime rush one?
- "Kuroko" no Basuke
when they go to America.
- Oh yeah, they go to America!
I completely forgot.
- And everyone's American,
but everyone's Japanese.
Like it's, it's a trip.
- Well, I mean, it's like the English
in "Devilman Crybaby," as well, right?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I have to do (speaking
in Japanese) next to that guy.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- It was Murase Ayumu.
- Oh yeah.
- And it's like, yeah, I mean-
- I mean, it's not a
win, no one wins there.
- Well yeah, no one wins.
I mean like his English was
probably the most decent
out of like all the other actors.
But like I had the exact
same thing like during break,
like all the actors were
coming up to me being like,
how do you pronounce this?
Or like, how do I make
this sound as fluent
and like naturally speaking as possible?
And I'm just like, dude you're
asking the wrong person.
This is set in New York.
I'm not even doing the accent correctly.
Why are you asking me?
Like, I'm struggling to say the letter R.
- You should've been
like, "I'm walkin' here."
- "I'm walkin' here!"
- Just say that.
That's what everyone says.
That's the meme, that's the meme.
- Just give him a copy of
every Martin Scorsese film.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- God.
- Jesus.
- Have you ever been recognized
in Japan for your voice work?
Like someone's spot on the street is like,
"Oh my god, I know you."
- Oh, I haven't had that before,
but I've had someone
ask me like at a cafe,
like when I was checking out,
I've had someone ask me if
I was a voice actor and-
- What just randomly?
- Yeah, just randomly.
- They could just feel the
voice acting aura from you.
- Maybe?
I don't know, like, yeah.
And so like, it was like a young male guy
and he was like, yeah, like,
"Do you by any chance to do voice acting?"
And I'm like-
- Is that like a pickup line in Japan?
Bro, that voice got me acting up.
- Are you a voice actor?
- I'm about to senpai your voice.
- "My Queen, are you the voice actor?"
- "My Queen, do you happen
to be a voice actor?"
- Says one word, "My Queen,
I will simp for you."
- Did you go to the checkout and say,
like it in a voice actor way?
Did you start barking, or?
You're a cat?
- No, or maybe did I?
I don't know, maybe I did.
- Give like the anime reaction lines.
Like, eh?
- Hontouni?
(all laughing)
- You can have a point card.
Hontouni!
- So, for like everyone watching,
who maybe want, aspires to
be a voice actor or actress,
what do you think it takes to be one
professionally in Japan?
- I think it's like,
obviously you need like
your acting skills,
but I think it's more like
being able to communicate
with the people around you and like, yeah.
Like, 'cause if you have a manager,
then you have, you have to
be in good relationships
with your manager
because they're the ones
picking who to push forward
for the audition and
stuff like that, right.
And you'll have to be
like doing good with,
the voice actors around you
and your senpais and yeah, I
think that's really important.
- So it's just social politics, isn't it?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's how it always is, though.
Like the entertainment industry
is always who you know,
and who you're friends with, right?
It's a bit unfortunate.
I mean, even YouTubing
is like that, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- True, true.
- It's who you're friends with, you know?
- I feel that's just like,
but I feel especially like
that on top of how already
socially, politically,
like charged, I guess
Japan is just in general.
- [Shu] Yeah, mm hm.
You have (speaking in Japanese)
and all that kind of stuff
on top of, like-
- It's so hard.
- In the entertainment industry.
- Yeah, I'm always like,
'cause like, even towards
your senpai, right.
You have, you want to be like,
if you want to become good
friends with like that person,
like, it's just so hard to decide
how polite you have to be towards them.
- Right, 'cause he don't
want to seem like a kiss ass.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause like, it's that fine line-
- Just rolling the dice.
- Yeah!
- It is, it's like you don't-
- Oh, sorry, go ahead.
- No, no, I was about to say, it's like,
it's that real fine line between,
showing that you respect your senpai,
but also not kissing their butt.
- Yeah, yeah.
And obviously, because
like, you know, in Japanese,
if you're too polite, it's like, you know.
- What's wrong with you?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Chill out, bro.
(all laughing)
- So that's really hard.
- Was that something you just had to learn
on the job I'm guessing, right?
- Yeah, it was really hard.
- 'Cause I guess like moving
from Australia to here,
like the social dynamics is
just so different from like,
from moving into
Australia, like we're more,
I'd say Western kind
of mentality, to Japan,
which is like very, very,
very, very different,
very, very, I don't know what the word
I'm looking for here is.
- It's like, if Japan is kind
of like a pyramid scheme,
Australia is just like.
- Do you mean just a pyramid.
You just did.
- If the social, okay,
let me rephrase that.
- It's the social multi-level marketing
that we're selling here.
- If Japan, socially, is like a pyramid.
- Hierarchy, that's-
- Like a hierarchy, right.
That's the word we were looking for.
If there's a pyramid,
then Australia is just,
everyone's kind of on the flat surface.
- [Shu] Yeah, yeah.
- It's like you refer to
your boss by your name.
Whereas like if you did that
in Japan, instantly fired.
- Yeah.
- Really?
- Or would it be a power move?
- No!
- Just like,
damn this guy is good, get him a role.
- No, definitely not.
Definitely not.
- I'd love if they did like,
you can let the top (speaking in Japanese)
can they just be like,
what's up, to the director?
- Oh, some people are.
- Like the legends go
like, hey, what's up?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I feel, though, that takes-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- A huge risk, yeah.
- 'Cause there seems to be so much,
I mean like voice actors here,
like very, very famous ones
are seen as like, almost like gods.
- They're like the top
celebrities, really.
- Right, right, right.
- I wonder if that, in
the work environment,
it kind of means they could
just walk up and be like,
"Yo, I own this place."
- I'm sure some of them, you
know, like with that much,
fame and power,
I'm sure some people would get cocky.
- 'Cause one thing I noticed
I was looking on on Twitter,
right, and the voice actor for Jonah
has like 1.2 million followers on Twitter.
I'm like, holy shit.
That's a whole, and it's, he's Japanese.
- Yeah.
- So like the market is only really Japan.
And I guess people who like JoJo,
but like that is a lot of followers.
- Like 1,000,000 in
Japan is the equivalent
of like 10,000,000.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's insane, like
that just blew my mind.
I was like, how many?
- Yeah, all of the, I feel like most
of the top-top voice
actors in Japan have like
that kind of level.
- A lot, yeah.
- Does being popular on social media
or being popular on TV,
does that help you get
a lot of roles in Japan?
Is that like a factor?
- Yes, it helps.
- A lot?
- Yeah.
'Cause you know, like if
you have more followers
then like you can, you know, what is it?
Like, not really advertise
more, but it's like,
people know you, so it's like.
- So they're more inclined
to like watch the anime.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So is there a lot of
voice actors in Japan
that are like, hey guys,
getting into TikTok now.
Is that a thing at all?
- Yeah, there are some
voice actors who do TikTok
and like a lot more voice actors now
are doing like YouTube, as well.
- Right, right.
- Yeah.
That's kind of the same in English.
Like a lot of voice, 'cause
you kinda have to have
a social media presence
now, unfortunately.
- Like the voice actor who did Gintoki,
he's huge on Twitter.
- Yeah.
- Like he's like,
he`memes the fuck out
of himself on Twitter.
He's like a lot of people
like, especially in the West,
just know him for that.
- Oh, it's great.
Everyone loves it when someone memes.
One thing I'm sure that the audience
is slightly curious about
and people who watch anime,
they want to be a voice actor in Japan.
That's the thing, right.
Have you ever seen someone
who wasn't native in Japanese
make it as a voice actor?
Is that like a thing?
'Cause I've heard often
to people who have tried,
but I haven't heard anyone
who's managed to do it
who like wasn't native or born in Japan.
'Cause I've heard that,
again, they are so strict
on all the pronunciation
and the way that you talk
that you do have to be native.
- Oh, I personally haven't seen anyone.
- Right, RIP weebs.
- I feel just like bilingual voice actors
is just not a market
that has been filled yet.
I can't really think of like
a notable voice actor in Japan
or in the West that can
do a role like that,
that is not in their native language.
- It's really hard because
like for voice acting,
especially in Japan,
you have to be able to act like
and speak in Japanese really fluently.
But you also have to
have that like Japanese,
bowing and keigo, you know
social skills, as well.
So I think because when
I first came to Japan,
I was really like shocked by all the stuff
that you have to do.
And so I think, yeah,
there's so many stuff you
need to do other than,
being able to act in Japanese.
And now you have to
like dance and sing and-
- RIP weebs.
- All these other stuff
that you need to do.
So it's like, yeah.
- I mean I know you've already said
that you started off like very young
pursuing this dream as well.
So you were like really
determined from a young age.
So yeah, I guess it takes
a lot of work, doesn't it?
- Rise and grind, weebs.
- And there is like, it's
a pretty harsh world.
So it's like,
you have to get used to people
saying harsh stuff to you.
If that makes sense?
Like-
- Oh don't worry, we've been there.
- Yeah, we've talked about this a lot.
Yeah, yeah.
- It's like yeah, and obviously because,
there's people on the internet as well,
but there's the people around you,
are like saying like this,
you need to work on this.
You need to work on that.
And this part of like your
acting or this part of you,
you need to fix and stuff like that.
So yeah.
- But that's good, though,
being able to take criticism, right.
Obviously as someone who's higher up
and they know what they're talking about.
- [Shu] Mm, mm, that's true.
- I mean, that's invaluable, right,
to get someone to be like, you're shit,
but you can't get better.
Let me tell you how.
Pyramid scheme.
(all laughing)
- Trained you.
- But I know, like because
when you go to school,
the voice acting school in Japan,
it's like the teachers there,
some teachers are really, really strict.
So like I know some students
who used to go there,
but because the teachers were too strict,
I didn't think they were
able to take it mentally.
And they kind of like,
started not coming to
school and stuff like that.
- It's definitely not a job for everyone.
- Trial by fire, trial by fire.
- In such a competitive
industry it's bound to happen.
Yeah, yeah.
- Especially in the
entertainment industry, as well.
I'm sure there's a lot of stories
that we will never hear the light of day.
- No fucks given, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's like if you suck, you suck.
You know, that's all it is.
- I am curious, as a
professional voice actress
who's like been in the field,
what'd you think of the VTubing scene
that's just like popped up
in the last year and a bit?
- Oh, well I think it's pretty cool
because I haven't really
done VTubing before.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But 'cause you use
your voice and you're kinda like-
- Playing a character.
- A lot of people are just
playing an anime character,
but just like, they just never,
they never break character
or they try to stay in character
for as much as possible, right?
- Yeah, so it's like,
you're acting as like
a character on YouTube,
but it's not the real you.
So you have to kind of like,
I think it's really cool because
you have to think so much
about the character and like
how that character would act
if something happens, you know?
- Yeah.
- Is that something you've ever thought
about getting into at all or trying out?
- Not really, but I think it would be fine
if I was able to try doing VTubing.
- 'Cause feel like VTubing
is such a weird line
between like acting as a character,
but also like a lot of VTubers also
put themselves into the role, as well,
and kind of "Break
character," quote unquote.
So I feel it's just like
another set of skills.
- Why build a character when
you already are one, right?
Like just use your personality.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Spoken like a true person.
- What can I say?
You know what, you'd be
a great animal VTuber.
- Oh!
- Just don't be a cat-girl,
just be a cat.
Just like make animal noises.
- There is a VTUber, actually,
that is just straight up a dog.
- Really?
- Yeah.
It's just like a Shiba Inu,
but their speaking like, a human.
- Okay.
- Oh really?
I could just be a cat.
- You could just be a cat.
- [Connor] There's like a
gorilla, as well, right?
- Yeah, just be a cat!
- Just be a cat.
- You don't need to act in anime, though,
you've already done that before.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Someone gives you
$10, just meow at them.
Meow louder?
- No, because like I feel,
'cause I feel like there's a
lot of, I don't know, like,
do you see a lot of people
in your field doing VTubing?
Or is it like,
is it something that's
has just been so new
that no one's really known
how to deal with it yet?
- Oh, it's pretty new.
So I don't really know anyone around me
who's like done VTubing being before.
- Right.
- But like, yeah,
because it's becoming
really like huge, right?
There's like so many
like VTubers on YouTube.
I think, you know, there
will be like a day when,
- When, yeah, professional voice actors
are dubbed on YouTube.
- I feel, though, it's like maybe
it might just be like a completely
different category right.
It's like, I feel a lot of
the professional voice actors
who have made it in the industry.
Probably think like, oh,
I don't really need to go down that route
because I've got, you
know, I'm getting roles.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Whereas like VTubers is a like kind of,
a lot of them I feel are
aspiring voice actors
who just want to build up a CV.
- [Shu] Right.
- And is like, I can do voices.
I can voice act, all that kind of stuff.
So yeah, I feel like going from VTubing
to professional voice acting
might be a viable option,
but I feel the other way
around might not really happen.
I dunno.
- Yeah, maybe, I don't know.
But like I know like
acting for games and anime
is really different to
acting for like VTubing.
So it's like, yeah, I don't know.
- You're not on script, are you?
- Have you ever been starstruck
when you're on the job?
- What do you mean by starstruck?
- I don't know, just--
- As in like,
you did an (speaking in
Japanese) with like a voice actor
or actress that you just loved-
- Yes, yeah!
- Like who's the most like,
whoa, person you ever met?
- Otsuka Akio-san.
- Whoa, really?
- Yeah.
- [Joey] That's fucking cool!
- I need a little context, who?
- Otsuka Akio is like, yeah, Snake.
He did "Solid Snake."
- Oh, whoa!
Okay, wow.
- Like he's the kind of,
he's the guy that has that
really distinct talking style
where he's like, I can't do an impression.
- Yeah, I can't do it.
- Please, go ahead, try, try.
- Oh my god, he's kinda like
the, I'm trying to remember.
Yeah, yeah, it's like,
yeah, yeah, yeah, actually Nabi does
a really good Otsuka Akio.
Yeah, yeah, he's just like
the "Solid Snake" voice.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You told my that.
- He's probably like the top five.
- Yeah, like--
- Like he's a fucking legend.
- Does he meme a lot on Twitter?
- I don't follow him on
Twitter, so I don't know.
- I feel like he does, right?
No?
Oh, I know the English voice does.
(all laughing)
- David Hayter, I know David Hayter.
- Of course.
- I fricking love those memes.
- Yeah, again, I feel the biggest memers
are usually the ones that
are kind of like the legends,
but I feel like even within the legends,
a lot of them, you know, take their stuff
like very, very seriously.
You know, the boys for like
Luffy for example, it's like,
you never see her like
memeing or anything like that.
You know, the voice for Gintoki
is like fucking whatever.
- He's just like playing
his character, right.
- He's literally Gintoki in real life.
Fucking awesome.
- How did you stay composed
when you walk in the room with them?
It's like, (Connor clearing throat).
- It was so I'm like nerve wracking
because I dunno, 'cause I've
seen him in like magazines
and I've read his books and like...
It was just-
- Did you play cool?
- I tried.
(all laughing)
I tried, but I don't
know if I was able to.
But there was like all these
other voice actors as well,
who were like really big, right.
So it's just, I dunno,
for me it was really hard
to like act...
- In front of them?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because you know, they're
like super, super good.
- Yeah.
- And you're like,
like you just came into the
industry and you're like.
- The bottom of the rank.
- Know your place.
- Hierarchy.
- No, no, pyramid scheme.
- Pyramid scheme.
- Pyramid scheme, I'm sorry.
Sorry, pyramid scheme.
- Have you guys ever been star struck?
By like anyone?
- I think we've talked about this.
Probably for me, it was Hiroyuki Sawano.
I think I've already told
the story about this.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh wow.
- Have you ever gotten
that with like a YouTuber?
Like someone in the same field as you?
- I don't think so, not yet, no.
- I don't know, kinda
after you do it for awhile,
you're just kinda like,
fuck this is boring.
We're all so boring.
I just, I sit in silence.
- I would be lying if I
said I wasn't like that
with Felix the first time.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, of course.
I mean like for me, YouTubers,
I view YouTubers as just like
people I want to hang out with.
- Yeah.
- It's you know,
'cause like we all do the same
thing at the end of the day.
I feel like once you get
past a certain like level,
you kind of get how-
- A certain rank?
- A certain rank in the hierarchy,
like all YouTubers kind
of like get each other.
'Cause we've all got to go
through like the same shit.
- Are you a big consumer
of YouTube content?
- Yeah, I watch a lot of YouTube.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- In English?
- In English and Japanese.
- Well, you have a YouTube channel, right?
- Yeah, I have a YouTube channel, too.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Wait, no, I think I
did watch one actually.
- Oh, really?
- I think so.
- I watched like your introduction video
on the YouTube channel.
- Oh really?
- I'm like, wow, this
chick is very Aussie.
Like holy shit, she is so Aussie.
- Wait, did you do a video
where you did a test to
see how Aussie you were?
- Oh yeah, I did!
- Okay, well I watched that one, yeah.
- With a slang?
- Yeah.
'Cause I'm not really fond
of like Australian slang.
I don't know if you are, but--
- It's terrible.
- What's arvo, it's nonsense?
- That's, what do you mean?
That's not slang.
- Like do you want a cuppa or like-
- We say that.
- A cuppa.
Well yeah, they say that in the UK.
- Oh you guys do?
- Cuppa is cup.
Wait, don't, don't.
What are you on about?
Cuppa's good.
- Cuppa's good.
It doesn't end with O,
so that's how we know.
I don't know why Aussies
end everything with O.
- It just rolls off
the tongue, doesn't it?
- I've never used bottle-o.
- You've never used bottle-o?
- I've never used bottle-o before.
- That's the liquor store
for you non-Australians.
- You're just adding a syllable
to a word that doesn't need
a syllable added to it.
- Yeah.
- I dunno.
- But like bottle-o I feel is like,
who the fuck came up with that?
It's a word, let me end a
word that ends in a vowel
with another vowel.
- Non-native speakers,
bottle-o is the slang
for bottle, right?
- No.
It's a bottle the store.
- It's a liquor store.
- You just thought it was
a bottle this whole time?
- I just though it was a
bottle this whole time.
Joey says it, I'm just like, what the fuck
are you talking about, Joe?
- How long have you known
Joey for?
- Not long enough apparently.
- What the fuck?
If you say it like, I'm just
popping over to the bottle-o.
- Okay apparently for even native speakers
we get fucking confused, as well.
- It's like, oh, I'm just going
to pop over to the bottle-o.
It means like I'm going
to go buy some alcohol
at the liquor store.
- Liquor store.
- Oh my god.
Sorry, Americans, we've hurt you too much.
- Yeah, sorry.
- Maybe we've been too harsh on you.
- So what are some of your
favorite YouTube channels?
What are you on?
- I watch a YouTube channel called JOLLY.
- Yeah, I think you mentioned
that earlier, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- What else?
- And I watch a lot of
animal videos on YouTube.
- Like what?
Give us a taste, give us a taste.
I want to get a better feel
of your character building in Japan.
- I watch, my favorite
dog is called a samoyed.
It's like a huge white dog.
- Okay.
- Wait, what's the YouTube channel?
What's it about?
- The channel's called MilkyBokiTan.
And it's like a YouTube channel
that has a samoyed dog and two cats.
- Okay.
- Right.
And it's just them living their life.
- You just watch that?
You just watch them?
- It's an animal slice-of-life.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I mean, that sounds nice.
Do you practice or?
- Well maybe.
- Is this research for roles?
- Sure it is, sure it is.
- And it's funny because for
like animal YouTube videos,
like the owners are called butlers.
- What?
- They're called butlers
because they take care
of the pets, right.
- I didn't know that.
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah.
So like--
- Animal YouTube terminology.
- Yeah.
- How do they ask you
to like subscribe and
smash the like button?
- They go,
(growling)
(all laughing)
- On the screen.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, just subtitles.
- Yeah, it just comes on as subtitles.
(all laughing)
- So you mainly watch animal videos?
- Yeah, I mainly watch animal videos.
- Damn.
- There is one
animal channel, actually,
that I watch quite often.
- Oh, really?
- It's like Korean channel,
I think, that it's this
guy who has like a pet,
I think it's a guinea pig,
but he makes miniature
models for the guinea pig.
- Oh, I've seen this one, right.
- Oh really?
- So like he uses arts and
crafts and like cardboard
and stuff like that and he made like
an (speaking in Japanese)
for his guinea pig.
- Wow!
- And a sound booth for his guinea pig.
And just like puts the guinea pig in
and just like sees what
the guinea pig does.
- Whoa.
- Cute as hell.
- Actually, no, I did get into like,
there was like, there's
like ant YouTubers.
- Oh, those fuckers.
- They're badass.
- Those are good.
- It's basically it starts off with like,
all right, well he's just
got a tank full of ants.
And then like the next video will be like,
I have made a giant
castle network of ants.
And his whole like living room
will be like tunnels of ants.
It's crazy.
- Was that the guy who was like,
who fed the baby cockroach?
- Yeah.
- And like the cockroach gives birth
as it's getting eaten alive by ants
and it's got like a hundred
million views or something.
And I'm just like.
- I can't watch insects.
- Yeah right.
- I just think of like, what
happens if one of these breaks?
- Yeah, right!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's what I'm constantly thinking.
- The house, it must be
like quarantined off,
like burn it down.
- It's literally a kill it with fire
kind of situation, right?
You've just gotta fucking
burn the house down.
- Well it's also like,
how do you bring a girl
into that house, right?
- Oh yeah, my bedroom is
just past the ant-slide.
Just move that out of the way.
- It's like, so what do you do for a job?
It's like, let me show you.
- There's like, what are
those YouTubers that like,
I know there's one that like
reviews, like rat traps.
That's a whole channel.
- What?
- I actually kind of like it.
- Why am I saying what?
Of course there's a channel for that.
- It's like a whole channel where the dude
just reviews rat traps, that's it.
- What?
- He like shows them.
- What makes a good rat trap?
- Well, you should watch
the YouTube channel.
That's a question I had-
- Now you've got me curious.
- How many types of rat traps
could there possible be?
- I think he has like over like 500 videos
on like different rat traps.
- Oh dear God.
- Oh wow.
- Yeah, show 'em what.
- Of course fucking Meyline knows that.
- [Crewman] She's been
nodding the entire time.
- She's like, yep, my favorite.
- This guy will make some insane trap,
and in the end, the one that works best
is always just like a ramp
that goes into a bucket.
That's just like the one
that always works best.
I know I'm getting off topic,
but there's some, there
is a weird category
of anything you want on
YouTube, someone's done it.
- If it exists, there's
a YouTube channel for it.
- But, you make your own
YouTube videos, right?
- Yes I do.
- Do you do it often?
- What's a channel called first
so people can check it out?
- It's called ShuTube,
for anyone who wants to--
- It'll be on screen right now.
- Yep.
- Yay!
- Now subscribe!
- Yes, please.
Or wherever it is.
Down in the description.
- What type of content
do you normally do on it?
- I usually talk in English, and I just,
I dunno, I just make stuff
about English and Japanese food.
Like cultural differences
and stuff like that.
- Yeah, culture stuff.
- Right.
- Do you like bring like
the Australian side a lot or
just every now and then?
- I think I do.
I think, yeah, I think I do.
- What made you wanna start it?
- That's the most stumped.
- Good answer.
- That's the most stumped
you've been all day.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh, I'm sorry.
- I think I just saw the lights flashing
like in between her eyes right there.
- So then were you like...
(Joey screeches)
- Why did I?
I heard that question reverb.
- Why did you start, start, start.
I don't know, just 'cause you wanted, huh?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Just 'cause you wanted to,
right?
- I just wanted to, because-
- All the cool kids were
starting YouTube channels.
- I'm interrogating and I'm like,
you think you're ready kid, huh?
- Oh, you're a voice actress?
Yo, let's see you become
a YouTuber then, okay.
- Ah man, yeah, so if people wanna
go check out the YouTube channel,
it's in the description,
so go check it out.
- Yes please!
- Yeah.
- Now you should make a video being like,
the truth about "Trash Taste."
- Easy million views, right?
- Yeah, easy million.
- Easy million views.
- "Trash Taste," exposed."
- "My experience on Trash Taste."
- I can't believe they
were such nice guys.
- Yeah.
- There was all these words.
(all laughing)
- One kept saying
penetrating, really weirdly.
- There was incest for some reason?
- There was a woman who like
put up the incest thing?
- Oh yeah, right, but be me.
And you see just this-
- That's what Meilyne held up!
- You just see this off screen,
and you're just like,
what am I supposed to
do with this, Meyline?
What am I, what am I
supposed to do with this?
- That's not just incest,
there's three fucking exclamation points.
It's like, incest!
- Like it's a fucking QuickTime event.
- Well I heard someone was doing
a sponsor or something,
and it was a live event.
Apparently someone was
holding up like cards,
telling them to do reactions.
And apparently the words
they wrote on the card
were just like nonsensical.
And they just didn't know what they meant.
I can just imagine being confused,
you're like, trying to promote a bike
and they're like drive.
And you're like what?
What am I supposed to do with that?
Drive, drive?
The bike drives, it drives, very fast!
Like what?
- Yeah.
When you were describing
your experience about how,
when you like flub up a line,
you just got to like stay
silent and just walk back.
- Right.
- I really hope
that you don't see when we need to record,
like, a sponsorship segment.
'Cause us trying to read a script
is just like a fucking bomb going off.
It's an absolute mess.
- Oh, really?
- It's like,
for some reason, I don't know what it is,
but the moment we get passed
the script, it's like,
you must learn English
from scratch once again.
You are not native in this language.
- True.
- Especially Garnt.
- Yeah, Garnt.
- Yeah, I'm the worst.
- Oh, really?
- Our sponsors take
twice as long as they should,
because Garnt is just like
having a mental breakdown halfway through.
He's like, "I can't do it.
I can't speak English."
- Just like the Windows
shut down, like, (Joey
imitating Windows chiming).
Just out of business, like,
it's like Garnt, come back.
- So I'm just having a guess here.
But I'm guessing that
you like anime, right?
- Yes.
- It was just like a feeling,
- Controversial thoughts.
- Shit.
- Just I just got that vibe.
I don't know where I got it from.
So what kind of anime do you like?
- I watch a lot of anime.
I like-
- Really?
Name every anime.
(all laughing)
- Oh, you're an anime fan?
- I like "Creamy Mami."
- Wow.
- That's not the first show
that I would have expected
to come from your mouth.
- I really like "Creamy Mami."
- When I first heard that, I was like-
- Sorry, what's "Creamy Mami?"
- It's like, there's a girl called Mami.
- Right.
- And it's just,
- Who's creamy.
- Yeah, she was-
- She hella creamy, dog.
- It's a very unfortunate name in English.
- That's what I was thinking.
- Yeah.
It's very unfortunate.
- "Creamy Mami."
- It's like a magical girl anime.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, that one, that one,
that one, okay.
- Classic.
- I think it was aired in the
1980s or somewhere around?
- That's your favorite?
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- Recent anime's I watch
"Boku no Hiro Akademia."
- Of course, of course.
- "Haikyu."
"Mawaru Penguindrum,"
"Psycho-Pass."
- Yeah.
- Oh like there's a, the
list, "Violet Evergarden."
- Oh damn.
- I love how you just, it's so Japanese.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- No, it's perfect.
- "Violet Evergarden" may hit it.
- The weebs watching this are
just frothing at the mouth,
they're just like, "Ah, Japanese!"
- I feel like I'm listening
to one of those PVs
that you see, right?
- "Violet Evergarden."
(all laughing)
- Airing this spring.
- "Psycho-Pass."
- Sorry carry on, carry on.
- Carry on, sorry.
- I watch "Shidonia no Kishi."
- Hell yeah.
- Of course.
- "Attack on Titan."
- Yeah.
- What else do I watch?
Oh, I watch so much.
"Yakusoku no Nebarando."
- Yup.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I love-
- Did you watch season two?
- Not yet.
- Okay.
We'll leave it at that then.
- We'll leave it at that.
- Let us know how you feel about it.
- I know, I can already tell
that you watch quite a fair bit.
Considering the fact that,
not only was your first
choice, "Creamy Mami,"
but also the fact that you
brought up "Mawaru Penguindrum."
- Oh yeah, I love it.
- And "Psycho-Pass" as well.
- Yeah I love "Psycho-Pass!"
- Yeah, I just kept nodding
with that penguin one.
I'm like, yep, yeah, what is that?
- "Mawaru Penguindrum" is like, oh God.
How do you explain that?
- It's really hard to explain.
- It's such a weird show.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You've definitely seen
clips of it, though.
- Probably.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's got a lot of animals.
- Yeah it's got a lot of-
- Which makes a lot of sense.
- I think I'm seeing a theme here.
- Yeah.
- Do you like "Beastars," by any chance?
- Oh, I watched "Beastars."
- Hell yeah.
Hell yeah, dude.
Of course you did.
- I'm trying to think
about that, "Zootopia."
- "Zootopia."
- I watch, I like "Pets."
- "Pets?"
- Wait isn't there a movie called "Pets?"
- Yeah, it's the-
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, like the Pixar or
Disney film or whatever.
- No, no, no, it's the Dreamworks.
- Dreamworks, yeah.
- I thought you
were just saying, I like having animals.
- Well, I mean I do
like having animals but.
- My God.
- Yeah.
- So, what were some of the anime
that were the biggest influences
for you to be a voice
actress when you were a kid?
- I think "Bleach" was.
- "Bleach?"
- Wow.
- I mean, yeah,
because obviously Hitsugaya
was voiced by a lady.
- Yeah.
- And all the actors were like, so like...
- I mean, they were cool as fuck.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- We've said a lot about
"Bleach," but I mean,
everything about it was cool.
- Especially Hitsugaya, right?
Like Romi Park is such
an amazing voice actor.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Especially in like, I think
she did Alfonse as well, right?
- Oh yeah, no, no.
She did Edward.
- Oh she did Edward.
That's right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I would know that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And she's Hange you
from "Attack on Titan."
- That's right.
- Oh yeah.
- Well that's a-
- Yeah, yeah, she's like wow.
Like, you know?
- Yeah, did you like,
when you were trying to get
into the voice acting field,
or like, how much research did you do
with fellow voice actresses in the field?
Or like fellow voice actors?
- As in like, what kind of research?
- Like, just like looking into it, right.
Because I, like, I know
there are some fans out
there in the anime field
who are like really, really into
like the voice actors and
voice actresses, right.
- Right.
- Were you like that, as well?
Where you like--
- Yeah.
(Joey speaking in Japanese)
- Yeah, I was a (speaking in Japanese).
I had like posters of
voice actors on my wall
and I would have like them as
my back, like as my wallpaper.
And so, like, I would like search
who voiced like, I would be
like, when I'd watch an anime,
I would always watch the credits.
And I would be like, oh!
Like you know, this was
voiced by this voice actor,
and I'm like, ah!
And so like, yeah.
- Did you ever, like, have,
did you ever sit through an anime
just because of a particular
voice actor was in it?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah?
I feel like, 'cause I have a
couple of friends who are like,
(speaking in Japanese) as well.
And they're like, they can
hear like half a second
of a phrase and they're immediately like,
yeah, that's that voice actor.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Instantly know it.
Did you ever get to the point
where you bought like voice CDs?
- Oh yeah.
- Oh my God.
- Wait, what is it, what's this?
- It's like,
there's a lot of like
different kinds of voice CDs
out in the world.
And there's like, oh,
there's like voice dramas.
And there's also ones where
they kind of like talk to you.
- Talk to you?
- Yeah.
- It's like, think of,
think of a podcast except your
doing the podcast with them.
And it's in like POV.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, this became an A-S-
- POV, a part of "Trash Taste."
- It's like an A-S-M-R
thing on YouTube now.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So I guess they made it,
like the OGs.
- Yeah.
And they use like-
- But they act as those characters.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And they also have like,
they have these microphones,
- Yeah.
- And it's kind of like, it's
shaped like a person's face.
- Ah, the Binaural ones.
- Yeah, yeah.
And then they use that to
take some of the audio.
So it's like, sometimes you hear the audio
from the right side and it kind of seems
like they're there.
- Oh, it's like the A-S-M-R.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it's the A-S-M-R mic, yeah.
- Norman made a mic, and it's
literally like a foam head.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it's really weird.
- It's kinda like that.
- It's super fucking expensive, though.
- Yeah, it's really fucking
weird to look at, as well.
Because you're talking
into like a fake head.
It looks really weird.
- But it's like, but it's, yeah.
For, I think decades
now, these voice actors
do these like drama CDs
where they were like,
for example, like, Romi Park
would do one of Hitsugaya.
And it's like, if Hitsugaya
was like hanging out with you,
like if you were on a date
with this particular character.
And they were like,
they would play out
these scenarios in POV.
- Right.
- Of like,
if you were in that position.
And like, people would
just like, listen to it.
- I mean, I've seen like
some of the short anime
that are kind of like that,
where it's just like POV,
you have a girlfriend.
(all laughing)
And it's just like that.
It's just like every episode,
there's like a different girl.
- It's literally "Dora the Explorer."
(all laughing)
Because I've seen some where they're like,
they would say a line and
then they kind of pause
for a couple of seconds
waiting for your response.
- I think I remember, I loved Code Geass.
And when I finished "Code Geass,"
I need more "Code Geass."
And they'd be like, the story
continues in an audio CD.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I was like,
what the fuck?
- Like a voice drama.
- I got it, and it just
sounded like a museum tour.
You know what I mean?
And I was like, what is this?
Oh, I can't listen to this.
- It's like, welcome to Britannia.
- It's like, Britannia was once a-
And I was like, what?
(all laughing)
What the fuck is this?
- It's like a lecture.
- Yeah, I was like what is this?
I don't wanna listen to this.
- (speaking in Japanese)
dig that shut up, man.
- I've actually only bought one audio CD
in my entire time of being an anime fan.
- What was it?
- It was for "Love Hina."
(group laughing)
- Hell yeah, dude!
- Wait who, who?
- Huh?
- Of who?
- No, it was like an audio drama.
- Oh, oh, oh, all of them.
- It was because like it
ended and I'm just like,
I need more.
The manga's not doing it for me.
I need to hear the voice
actors and actresses
playing out the ending of this.
And so I fucking bought it.
And it's the only audio
drama I've bought so far.
And I don't regret
anything, it was amazing.
- I think the closest
I ever got to that was,
I used to tune in, 'cause
like a lot of voice actors,
especially like the top
ones do like radio shows.
- [Shu] Oh yeah, they do.
- Like talking about
their role in the anime,
of like, you know, if
they like work together
on an anime or whatever.
And they would go for however long
the anime spans for basically.
So like the closest I
ever got to that was,
I used to like tune in
every week to "Kaji Yuki"
and "Shimono Hiro."
- Oh!
- It was like "Attack
on Titan" on like radio.
And it was really cool
because they would openly just
kind of poke fun at the show
a lot of the times, as well.
But it's also like, I mean, yeah,
you guys are the voices of the show.
So I guess that gives you
some credit to be like,
that was kind of ridiculous, wasn't it?
Is it still a big thing
in Japan, the audio CDs?
- It is, I think it's getting bigger now.
- Wow.
- 'Cause, yeah-
- I guess MP3s are easier to sell, right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I mean like we just establish,
it's more about building
yourself up as like a,
kind of like an idol in some cases, right.
- Is there like anything,
I mean, how long,
how many years have you
been doing voice acting now?
Like professionally.
- Five years now because
I debuted in 2016.
- Right.
- So, five years now.
- Five years now.
Is there any like voice
role or type of character
that you haven't done yet that you really,
really want to do?
Like, I want to do like
a (speaking in Japanese),
or I want to do like a maid or like just,
any like archetypes that you want to do?
- I want to try like a boy.
- A boy?
- Ah.
- Yeah, 'cause-
- I guess that's the Romi Park in you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Hitsugaya right there.
- Like (speaking in Japanese).
I wanna try to voicing a
(speaking in Japanese).
- I mean like a lot of light
kind of younger boy characters
are voiced by females, aren't they?
- Yeah, yeah, they are.
- Like all the time,
because people keep forgetting
that like Ash or like Naruto
are voiced by females.
- And Luffy, as well.
- Luffy, as well.
- Luffy is voiced by a female.
Or Goku is voiced by a female.
- Kids are expensive.
(all laughing)
- Kids normally don't have
proper voice acting training,
you know?
- Kids also are not
very good at taking direction.
What do you mean goo-goo ga-ga?
I said, do the line.
- Just have a teste pop off.
- Yeah, exactly.
Jesus Christ.
- Oh my God,
if Goku was voice by like a
young boy and he just like,
fucking has a teste pop complex
or a (speaking in Japanese)?
- [Garnt] That would be hilarious.
(Joey squealing)
- We need more voice cracks in anime.
That's what we need.
We need more realistic
representations of puberty.
- Hell yeah.
- Have you ever done any events
where you meet your fans
or anything like that?
- Yes, I have.
I'm in this, like a local
dance unit called Prima Porta.
- Okay.
- And we had this thing
called watashikai where
we like hand the CDs
to the people who bought the CDs.
- Right, right.
- And yeah, we were able to like
talk to the fans for like
30 seconds, a minute.
- Damn, they really speed run that.
- Yeah, really speedy.
But yeah, yeah.
- Is it kind of like the same thing,
as in like, with like, I
know a lot of the watashikai
with like idols, for instance, that time-
- It's the handshaking event.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- But the time extends
depending on how many CDs you bought.
- Oh, we didn't have that.
It was kind of like-
- Hierarchy.
- Yeah.
- Did you have to do that
handshaking thing, as well?
- Oh no, we didn't do hand shaking.
It was more like waving.
- Oh.
- Okay.
- And just talking.
- Waving in close proximity.
- Well, I saw videos of
like guys not letting go
and like security like dragging them out.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I guess it is a bit--
- It's so scary.
- Yeah, it's a risk, yeah, definitely.
Is it weird?
Like when the first time
that you had to do that,
is it a weird feeling to be like, wow,
these people came from me?
- Yeah, it feels really like,
'cause like, on the internet, like SNS,
like you don't know how many people
are actually like into you.
Like, I mean, they might
comment and stuff like that,
but you don't know, if they
really, really like, you know.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Willing to go to an event.
- We feel the same.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then so when you actually
go and like meet people
and they're like, "Oh my gosh,
I've been wanting to meet
you for like so long,"
you're like, I'm so glad I did this job.
(all laughing)
- I'm so glad I defied my parents.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It makes it all worth it.
- It does, yeah.
- You feel like, wow,
somebody cares.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just being able to
meet all those people.
And even if you can't
like talk to everyone,
just seeing them and
like, when you go to like,
when you attend events and stuff
and they're like calling out your name,
it's like, oh!
You feel really happy, so.
- Like, for me?
You're doing it, you're cheering for me?
- Yeah yeah.
- Oh my God.
- You're the best maid!
Best POV of my life.
(all laughing)
That's also fun.
Do you go to many events then?
Well actually now I
imagine it's not so much.
- Yeah, yeah.
But yeah, I, like before
this all happened,
yeah, I used to attend
events pretty often.
- Have you been on the other side?
- Ah, yes, I actually have.
Like before going into
this industry, like,
I'd buy tickets to like concerts.
- Yeah.
- And lives and I would like,
- Buy the CDs?
- I'll buy the CDs
and I'll buy the goods.
- Yeah.
- She waved at me!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It'd be really awkward if you'd turn up
to the voice session and they'd be like,
why do I know you?
I swear I've met you.
Where, I just can't put my finger on,
and you're like, nowhere, nowhere.
We did not meet.
- It was so, it was funny 'cause one time
I went to like a concert
and it was like a female
voice actors concert.
- Right.
- And like, her fans
were like mostly male,
but I really liked her.
So like I went there by myself
and all the fans were like male, right?
So like, it'll be like one
girl and all these males.
And because, I think they thought
that it was really rare that a girl
would come to that concert.
- Yeah, yeah.
- They were kind of like, to me, like,
"Oh, if I get too like
noisy using like the blades,
like please let me know."
And like, (speaking in Japanese).
- Wow.
- Like oh that's so nice.
- Were they trying to impress you?
- I don't know, I don't know.
- I don't mean to brag, but
I can wave these bad boys
for two hours straight.
- Yo, yo, is this your first concert?
Let me show you how a pro does it.
- Sorry. Let me put away my guns.
(all laughing)
- I felt the exact same way when I went
to the Sailor Moon Museum.
- Oh!
- 'Cause it was like
five years ago in the Mori
Arts Museum in Roppongi.
And they had a Sailor Moon Museum.
And I was like, I fucking
love "Sailor Moon."
So I went.
Imagine room full of just
like tiny, like Japanese girls
like fawning over "Sailor Moon,"
meanwhile, in the middle of it,
there's this massive white dude
just being like, that's so fucking cute.
Oh my God, dude, I fucking love Mercury.
I felt, I've never had
so many women stare at me
for all the wrong reasons.
It was the weirdest experience of my life.
- You do not belong here, Joey.
- And they were all
looking at me like, what?
Is he like staff?
Why is he here?
- Is he security, maybe?
- I was like, what?
Am I not allowed to like "Sailor Moon?"
Fuck you.
Yeah, but is there any
like kind of social media
that you want to shout out?
Like I guess your YouTube channel,
anything you want to
shout out to the audience?
- I have a Twitter account.
If people want to follow it?
- They will follow.
- Just follow it, follow it.
- Follow, follow!
- We'll do it for you.
- Also, Shu's YouTube channel, ShuTube?
- ShuTube.
- What else?
- That's all I have.
- That's it?
- Yeah.
- No TikTok?
- No TikTok, no Instagram.
- How do you do the trendy dances?
- Yeah, actually, TikTok would
be like the perfect platform
to show off all your skills
that you literally trained years for.
- That's true.
- Like your singing skills
where you literally had
to hide it from your mom.
- Yeah.
- Your voice acting skill.
- You can literally do that on TikTok.
- Maybe I should download TikTok.
Follow YouTube, follow Twitter.
- Yeah.
- Go, go.
- Buy her drama CDs.
- Yes, please.
- POV, you are a princess.
- And listen to her in
your favorite anime.
- Mm hm, yes please.
- Yeah.
- And games.
- And games and everything.
- And everything, yes.
- Yeah, check out her stuff.
But in the meantime, you can
check out the lovely patrons
who are just,
- Look at them!
- On screen right now.
- Oh my God.
- Who's your favorite patron, Shu?
Is it that one or that one?
- Just point somewhere on the screen?
- What, what?
- There'll be words.
- Oh, this one!
- [Connor] Oh that's a
good, oh I like that one.
- Frothing at the mouth now.
But yeah, if you like to support the show,
then make sure to head on over to our page
on patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the SubReddit.
And if you hate our faces,
listen to us on Spotify.
But yeah, thanks for coming, Shu.
- Thank you for inviting me.
It was really fun!
- I hope you had fun.
- It was really fun.
- Even through some of the dodgy words
that were used or whatever.
- Shu's manager is just like sweating.
- I'm sorry you have
to see this off screen.
That was like a bad-
- We can hold on to that.
for any like emergent,
for any like emergency situations.
We can just like,
- Pass.
- If ever there's a
situation, I'll just be like.
- One day, one day
maintenance can be like,
guys, I have the perfect,
perfect thing to show.
We'll keep it for the next
hentai episode, maybe.
- Yeah, definitely.
But yeah, hopefully you
guys enjoyed this episode
and we'll see you guys next one.
- [All] Bye!
(jazzy music)
(singer vocalizing)